oh
you see your hands
[Music]
put your [ __ ] hand up there jesus
christ
keep your [ __ ] hands on the wheel
keep your [ __ ] hands on the wheel
i'm sorry who else is in the car that's
my butt
put your foot back in i'm so sorry
god dang man man i got i got shot the
same way because i wasn't before
okay well when i say let me see your
hands you put your [ __ ] hands up
i'm so sorry you got him
dang man put your hands on top of your
head
[Music]
hands on top of your head hands on top
of your head
step out of the vehicle and step away
from me all right step out and face away
step out and face away from the please
don't shoot me please man i'm not gonna
shoot you step out and face away i'm
gonna get out man
please don't shoot me man
i just lost my mom man
step out and face away please don't
shoot me myself
please don't shoot me man step out and
face away you're not shooting me man i'm
not shooting step out and face your way
okay
okay please please please man
please please i didn't know man
get out of the way
hey you come back stay in the car
stop resisting that i'm not yes you are
you can ask mr
oh
i just came over to get my phone you see
i'll have a curse or nothing
my daughter is on her way to get me off
mr adam knows me sir
why is he getting all squirrely and not
showing us his hands and just being all
weird like
we have problems all the time when they
come special when that man stood that
gun like that
my name is oh my name is can you spell
it
s-h-a-w-a-a-n-d-a s-h-a
you listen to me
yeah right yeah
[Music]
127.75
okay well so here's the thing all right
someone passed a fake bill in there
um we come over here he starts grabbing
for the keys and all that stuff
starts getting weird not showing us his
hands i don't know what's going on so
you're coming out of the car so just
hang tight right here
stay right here please
oh ouch are you wanting something right
now nothing
cause you actually all right let's go
man let's
[Applause]
oh
to do man i'm not a resistor man i'm not
i'm not you can ask him they know me you
know
god man we'll do nothing like that yo
what is
going on look at my rhythm i'm not the
kind of guy
don't even buy myself man please i'm
just claustrophobic
that's it you're still going in the car
anything sharp on you i won't do
anything anything
no sir nothing nothing cause i don't
have nothing
why y'all doing me like to them i was
like please crack you're doing it for me
and stuff
[Music]
and i understand that that people do
stuff
and it's good
[Music]
i don't wanna try to win i don't want to
try to win
i don't want to win i i'm not the voting
ain't going to win i'm just above me i
got anxiety i don't want to do nothing
i'll roll the window down man i'm scared
as [ __ ] man
give me that breathing when that's not
breathing it's going to
i'm not trying to win i'm not trying to
win i get on the ground anything
i can't
[Applause]
my wrist man my wrists let it please
okay
is
[Applause]
oh
which i love you you got hubble
mine's in my side it's listed it's
labeled it says
something right it's cold man
oh
my face did a bad dare get his legs up
let's go
all right hopefully park's still sitting
on the car there
he was acting very shady was in there
i'm assuming
two other people with them
uh-huh
okay breathe
okay breathe please dick
appreciate it get up get in the car man
i will i can't move
on a weed pipe on them there might be
something else with it might be like pcp
[Music]
please
come on
i cannot breathe
don't kill me
we tried that for 10 minutes
you roll them on the side
okay
oh
your body language
bro you
yeah know think he was passing off
you think that's cool
washington street
i'll survive
[Music]
welcome over here
what is that what do you think
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
there we go
[Music]
oh
um
[Music]
[Music]
don't touch them
[Music]
[Music]
oh
strangers
[Music]
how funny would it be if i said look
look no hands and then just dropped the
mug
and made the interns clean disgusting it
wouldn't be funny at all oh it would be
wonderful good morning
we're starting a little early today by
the way the uh you can use the uh
hashtag is it uh crowder
chauvin trial there it is i keep saying
crowder chauvin
because i'm french canadian i speak it
properly
um i'm an affected [ __ ] so we have
gerald here we have quarter black
garrett here we have dave landau you can
follow him
on the twitter at dave landau right or
land out dave atlanta dave
and now dave and that's wonderful
because before we are going to be
covering the uh derek chauvin
trial the opening statements here today
let us know we may be covering it
throughout the week i don't know how
long it will go this is kind of a little
free flow but you can follow dave
because he can't follow me on twitter
i've been suspended again
for one reason uh here's what's funny
about this one
so i was suspended uh last week
okay and then i
was unsuspended and i posted one tweet
which resulted in my next suspension
immediately and the tweet was so twitter
has publicly stated to congress that it
fairly enforces its policies and
provides detailed information about
alleged violations
yesterday they suspended me for the
third time in a month refusing to list a
reason
or a tweet and question and i think we
have the uh the overlay here
um they never they never gave me a
reason it says reason
or violation right and it's blank ah you
would think like just put in a middle
finger emoji
something just make something up just
make something up
racism but the point here is
the only tweet that went up from my
previous suspension
to my new suspension is the one
criticizing twitter for the suspension
so now twitter
will suspend you for simply pointing out
that they are suspending people without
cause
uh there's clearly no violation unless
it's saying that look they've testified
saying that they give you a reason so i
you know what whatever i i thought
well it started as 24 hours right and
then it moved to now it's six days
so what if you try to log in does it
reset the clock every time again like
last time
i have no i have no idea i really just
use twitter now i
put a joke occasionally but mainly just
for advertisements for shows
right because why bother right it just
upsets everybody no matter what you say
right well especially jack dorsey yes
he's a real prick
he's he's an absolute prick brother's
blood
stained volleyball oh my gosh
that's the worst beard ever um you
shouldn't grow it if that's what it
looks like yeah should cut it off
we don't have a drinking game today no
we have a fentanyl game oh boy
oh my oh my god okay we're going to give
you a little bit did you see what i was
doing in the bathroom
so this is about that we do have
security cameras
it's a private business if you don't
like it take a walk
sobriety over um
so we want to watch this along with you
and of course uh if you want to follow
me you can join me at mud club louder
with crowder.com
mug club um opinions here before we go
to the trial let me let me give you a
little bit of setup and then we'll go to
um that's why we just showed you the
full 20 minute arrest
we have some technical issues i guess
let me know token on once we're good
give me a thumbs up so that i don't
feel like i'm uh walking a tightrope
here um so chauvin
now chauvin
i'm not sure what you said there's
horrible i actually have a lot of fans
in french canada
yeah there are apparently some
conservatives out there do you speak oh
francais i do that was my first language
what do you think just happened i don't
know what has happened i
i'm not like gibberish to me
i don't know i just can't tell anymore
i'd like to just throw it out there to
see what
people correct me so he has three
charges against chauvin it's
second-degree manslaughter second-degree
unintentional murder third-degree murder
judge cahill previously dropped the
third degree murder charge
saying that it didn't apply um now we
have as defined by minnesota law to give
you context
uh second degree manslaughter would
require
that says by the person's culpable
negligence whereby the person creates an
unreasonable risk and consciously takes
chances of causing death
or great bodily harm to another um
so these charges don't seem to apply
here yeah
um and we have some cl let me see what
do we have remember keep keep in mind
too
as far as how biased this is earlier in
the trial they did
and let me be clear i think we all have
sort of opinions yeah
um that's why we showed the 20-minute
arrest where you see the full footage
what i
what i do not think this is an example
of is of an officer going out and
lynching a black guy
right i think this is an officer several
officers who were incredibly patient
a man who was incredibly non-compliant
who was very high
who was distraught who had covid and
after 20 minutes of refusing to comply
i think then you had an officer who was
frustrated
used the proper police protocol to put
his knee on his neck which i think is
horrible protocol and then didn't follow
rolling him over to his side because he
didn't want to take chances because he
couldn't control him
yeah that being said obviously george
floyd
not a saint this is a man who picture
this it matters because the officer knew
this the officer knew george floyd and
we were told
the officer chauvin knew george floyd
they worked at the same nightclub
therefore it must be racism
or maybe he knew that george floyd
jammed a pistol
into a lady's stomach in front of her
toddler during an armed
violent home invasion okay and so you
don't take those chances with someone
who is
that big has a history of that much
violence
and is high out of his mind that being
said i don't think chauvin
chauvin how do people say it in america
is a saint
either i think there are mistakes all
around it's a tragedy
but certainly not an example of a modern
day lynching
and certainly not indicative of the
non-existent statistics
of unarmed black men being shot through
that was the last epidemic before the
pandemic right we have an epidemic of
unarmed black men being shot well
that's not true more unarmed white men
are shot and far more police officers
are shot
by black men yeah and we wouldn't really
be bringing up a lot of their history
unless people were saying you know this
cop is horrible and a racist and we're
like okay well let's look at the facts
and see if that's true
it doesn't look like that's true and it
doesn't look like this was motivated by
that
okay now george floyd is a saint what
does it look like that's true and it
also looks like the police officers knew
that wasn't true when they stopped him
like all of these things matter
because they've been put out there right
right murals of george floyd like he's
the second coming
well actually not too long ago they
actually compared him at the
uh jury selection to jesus christ we
would agree
that specifically as worded the court
could grant this
with respect to the shall we say parties
identified specifically in that motion
i i have to ask
how did this even become a motion how
did this become a possible answer
at trial i i think your honor um
one of our witnesses mentioned something
like this
we do not in context your honor i don't
really want to
go into you prepare your witness by
telling them
that analogy absolutely will not come
anywhere close to being admitted
clearly understood under rule 403
well that seems pretty self-explanatory
hey really quickly we're having a
problem here with our truck we're going
to pause the show for two or three
minutes and be right back so we don't
miss the trial
we have some more clips for you and
fentanyl games right back
don't go anywhere
[Music]
one
[Music]
um
[Music]
now
[Music]
protests continue across the country
this evening and we want you to know of
course uh that though there are some
individual protesters who are agitated
it is not the norm these protests are
largely peaceful
many people look back at the
demonstrations at selma and wonder what
would i have done
would i have marched across that bridge
or would i be standing
on the other side well i have an answer
for you
and my answer is a question
what are you doing now now tanya how
would you describe the attitude on the
ground
there uh we go now live to our woman in
the field tanya franks tanya
well chris first i want to say that was
inspiring not many today have the
courage to say what you just did
your wife is a lucky woman well that's
very kind of you to say tanya
and uh might i say you look positively
dishy this evening
well as far as the attitude on the
ground you know folks are entirely
peaceful but
far from happy just imagine if every day
when you left home
you didn't know whether you'd be coming
back you might be a little upset too
well tanya in my line of work that's
always a possibility but i know that
many in the audience might not
understand what that's like
no tanya was that a man on was that a
man on fire hard to tell with the flames
chris
might have been a really muscular lady
so tanya um
what are the people on the ground saying
there yeah we're gonna burn this
[ __ ] down three one three
cheers cbs is open for business y'all
take what you need [ __ ] a
fitting tribute to the memory of george
floyd chris
yeah yo who did that that's a
[ __ ] with a grill charged
evening
to be certain now some people are asking
why is this happening now
haven't things gotten better but there
are still persistent and pervasive
inequities in this country and these
protests are a reaction to that
and aside from a string of isolated
incidents very small
things have been pretty peaceful very
tame any final thoughts tanya
oh uh hello sir uh
what's your name
i'm sorry that was unfair allow me to
reframe uh the question
good sir where might i ask is tonya
oh she dead
[Applause]
yo yo i got an apple watch dog yeah
the language of the unheard we'll be
right back
[Music]
[Music]
oh
there we go that's the sound of getting
it right this time there's no there's no
sip
no the zip only happens once the sip
only happens once so then it's got
technical difficulties we're all set we
have gerald dave landau land out dave
quarterblack garrett uh uh so we are now
uh we're waiting on court tv
yeah because they're the least likely to
copyright strike us
uh thank you for being back with us uh
the promo well done the promo code the
hashtag is crowder
shaving stream if i say
chauvin shut up okay everybody watching
correct shot
correct i've had this so many times i
think you were with me when i was
ordering one time out the fiend dumas i
was like
feign fandom and i know it's fangio is
the right way yeah it's a beer
and i'm trying to say it the right wrong
way for i mean i go find you on she goes
i don't know what is that the finn de
monde i'm like
sure yeah we don't have it and i go okay
then i'll take the word is mo dit i'm
like
the the mode the mo dite i'm like you're
getting no tip
um let's hear right now judge hears
motions before opening statements let's
go to this and then i have some clips
and some
pretext for you
analysis of that situation is that the
public is that the public defendant for
my cousin vinnie
he's already yeah
trying or wanted to resist arrest that
he was
trying to um uh
fight with the officers intentionally
that he was
is this from us or is there audio that
bad i think i think
okay can
i spend time in prison i wanted to bring
it to the courthouse
then i wear this mask after a bunch of
men grabbed me
think about it uh as far as
um mr shobin's intent or knowledge it
vis-a-vis that uh
all right so are they all under the
emotions right yeah i don't know if
they're all on fentanyl right now
um we already had the clip of them
referring to uh to
george floyd is uh jesus christ which it
will not be admissible thank god
no yeah so this has resulted in bill h.r
1
280 um which is of course the george
floyd policing bill
hey it's always nice when you commit
multiple violent felonies and jam
a pistol into a lady's gut with her
toddler watching and you get a policing
bill named after you
well it's exciting and murals and murals
yeah it's always
it's like che guevara he gets murals
well a great guy
i really do think the end there was uh
not good i'm gonna go ahead and say it i
think uh
i think it was bad oh yeah i think it
was bad too listen i think this thing is
a tragedy all around but the pro
that's been ideal the problem is they're
using this to try and create a new bill
right based on the idea that this was
simply a racist cop going out
and uh attacking a black man yeah and
that's not true so the bill withholds
funds from departments that do not ban
chocolates
there was no chokehold applied just to
be clear labels chokehold civil rights
violations so i guess you'd rather be
beaten by a night stick
uh bans racial profiling okay i don't
know what that means
how do you ban racial profiling if
someone commits a robbery
and they're white blonde hair right they
look like you yeah
can you imagine if they look like me if
they look like george floyd
well they just describe you right no no
you can't that's what we're saying like
now it's like all right well they look
like well he was
um um
baba are you singing beach boys i am
because i'm uncomfortable
and there's an autonomous zone behind me
the news has been doing that forever
though where they just try to dance
around who you're looking for they're
like
right probably likes grape drink dark
hair
unless he's white dark eyes the shooter
who was white and like actually he was
arab
the shooter who was of unidentified race
well okay
well he's white until he's not yeah but
you know there was a lot of times in
this country where that was the opposite
right so you know um ends qualified
immunity which means that they can be
civilly liable police officers a lot of
people don't understand that that means
that any time a cop should even if it's
fully justified
if someone is shooting a police current
shooting a police member currently
and the man returns fire and the person
dies the family can sue him
just like which will happen it'll happen
every single time
uh national police misconduct registry
available to the public
okay i understand the idea of having a
national registry available to the
public seems like a problem
considering that you get banned from
twitter it's considered doxing if you
just say hey ill on omar's the office
today signing a crappy bill
right um none
i think there's a pretty important
registry that's already out there too
yeah i think it's you know uh and and uh
just to keep in mind too there they
won't be talking about this the
toxicology report
yeah fentanyl uh methamphetamine
marijuana and of course he had coveted
so in any other scenario this would be
listed as a covid death not saying
that's what happened
just like i don't think the guy who
tried to blow his head off with a
shotgun in michigan was a cove of death
but there we are he was listed as one so
this is this is a remarkable
inconsistency and
the truth is this is going to be used to
set a narrative
um which is important that well we need
to fix the problem right now this is the
bill we need to fix the problem of
unarmed black men being shot
on mass from uh police officers that's
not happening
no and then this isn't even a case of
police brutality necessarily this is a
case of poor training or poor execution
of training right
right at a certain point you have to
roll this guy over and we'll we'll get
to all of those things but people are
using this like you said to justify a
whole slew of changes like defunding
police officers around the country
right which doesn't really work out so
well as well so two thousand percent
increase in homicide in seattle and
portland and certain areas of the
country you know if you're getting away
now with only a multi-hundred percent
increase in violent crime
and homicide major cities you're
actually doing really well you're like
the rudy giuliani
you are doing really well you are tough
on crime i think you're including chaz
numbers
right yes that's a totally different
place it's technically a republic
it's its own country i'm sure they can't
sustain themselves
with an open starbucks yeah they still
they're great people okay yeah they are
very nice overall countries do they
waited for us to give them bottled water
and food yeah
right yes fantastic which by the way
what we're talking about this we'll talk
about this tomorrow or whenever we're
not doing the
the trial show this idea that in georgia
they're banning people from giving water
oh that's not true it's not it's not
true at all you can't
anyway it's not true it's [ __ ] if it
sounds like bull sounds like [ __ ]
smells like [ __ ] probably [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] we'll talk about it just
don't believe it for a second despite
what chris wallace says
oh my gosh why can't you give water to
people in roading lines
you're an idiot and i hate you chris
wallace so let's get to the epidemic
really quickly before we move this is
the narrative they want to set and if
this
guy does not fry there will be riots in
the street oh yeah
uh our korean in chief here actually
made a good point he said this is kind
of like my
oj only in reverse yeah and it mirrors
when you think about it
oj after rodney king the riots right
this is a guy who obviously was
allegedly guilty well guilty in the
civil court
uh and because of the racial tension
because of the issue because they didn't
want to deal with these ramifications
with these riots
they let the guy go in this case it's
post riots we're talking about two
billion dollars in damages
over 900 officer casualties tens of
people who were killed in the black
lives matter these are the most violent
expensive riots that have ever taken
place in american history
and people don't want more of this to
happen and so they're going to have to
convict
this guy whether in any other scenario
he would be convicted or not
now this is being used to set a
narrative and i just want to set the
stage here really really quickly
uh that police are shooting unarmed
black men and wreck
it is not true so 2019 is the last time
we have these full numbers
nine unarmed black men were shot by
police 19 unarmed white men i know
you're saying yeah but they make up a
high percentage of the population
but actually uh 53 percent of known
homicide offenders in the united states
right are black 60 of robberies are
black so when you consider that
violent crime is committed
disproportionately and i hate this has
to come out of my mouth
i hate that i have to say black white
but the fact is right now they're going
to be talking
about white black i was listening to npr
this morning i said derek chavez
who is derek chavin who is white shot
unarmed uh sorry put his knee on the
neck of unarmed george floyd
who is black that was in there yeah yeah
exactly so you have to respond to it
um but let me touch on the statistics
thing you said you're
absolutely right it doesn't matter what
the percentage of the population is when
you use statistics you have to use them
in a way that is precise and
actionable you don't want the population
number you want the cop interaction
number how many people of
all the different races are the police
interacting with and what are the
outcomes
yeah that shows a much different picture
well that's also important the
interactions do you know
you probably don't know this uh do you
know how much
more likely a police officer is to be
shot
uh or killed by a black male than he is
to shoot an armed black male
uh wait if you take a guess how much
more likely is it for a police officer
to be killed by a black man
i don't want to it's 18 and a half times
wow i wouldn't know how to even gauge
the percentage
well i guess my what i'm wondering
though is what is conviction versus
arrest rate because there could be an
argument there inside the system once
like yeah sure more black people may be
convicted but how many arrests were
there compared to the two races
well substantially more right right yeah
substantially the interactions
is off the charts in fact the the black
lives matter group before this had been
making the argument for decades that
police were just stopping black people
randomly so it takes the numbers into
astronomical figures there's no way i'm
just playing
no no no i appreciate so here we have so
i have this number exactly
53 of known homicide offenders in this
country are black 60
of robberies but they make up only 25
percent of those shot by police
okay so half in relation to the crimes
committed and police officers are 18
times more like 18 and a half times more
likely to be shot or
sorry to be killed by a black man than
shooting an unarmed black man by the way
of these nine
unarmed black men who were shot in 2019
one of them one of the unarmed black men
uh blackman tried to run over the
officer with his car no
so a car technically uh
i mean think about that for a second
like these things matter a car is not
armed he's trying to run over a police
officer
right the point is if you try and over
correct and now make sure that police
officers cannot do their job and you
defund them because of systemic racism
which statistically does not exist in
the police force
then we have a problem yeah and that's
why the majority of black americans
don't want less of a police presence
they want at least the same amount as
they have now
or more do we need police reform sure we
need to make sure that unions aren't as
strong in the police as they are
this wall of silence we need to make
sure that police have their authority
constrained to constitutional parameters
i have a problem with police
who do you think they would have to send
out to round up people with the
executive orders with
firearms probably police officers when i
see police officers arresting ladies at
soccer games because they're not wearing
their double mask
that's a problem that being said we need
to address the real issue
and not the race-baiting that is taking
place in the mainstream media and that's
what's going on today yeah and you can't
do that
until people start to actually look at
what the problem is and i think dave
that's what we're trying to do is to set
it up and say
look there is a problem we need to solve
it but
what is the problem it's not what
they're saying it is that you're just
going to get shot randomly by police
officers because you're black
so what really is going on well that is
yeah that is obviously a message that
people want to put out and there's no
denying that but at the same time how do
you solve something that's an individual
basis when you're painting it
as a broad stroke it doesn't really work
right it's all an individual thing
this particular situation the guy who
kneeled on his neck
i think personally was an [ __ ] and
was responsible for his death he took it
too far at the end when he didn't need
to
right now that's not speaking for the
other police that's not talking about
cops across this country who are now
being accused of it
right or them getting defunded because
of a singular situation
right that's the problem is we're taking
single things done by individuals
and putting color stamps on them and
that's dangerous and i would take it
even a step further and say uh
uh i i would give this guy
more away officer shoving than than you
are um for a couple of reasons this is
what they were trying to do to put the
knee up so you're talking about the knee
on the neck
they're trained by the police department
put the knee in the neck it's very
stupid it's also not an asphyxiation
but we need to acknowledge the fact that
they train police officers in this
department to do
what he did right they trained them to
turn someone over
afterward which he did not do but that
wasn't the media outcry
the media was why would you put your
name in his name because he was taught
to so your problem here is with the
police
training department and i've been saying
this for a long time we've had jocko on
oh yeah police before they go out they
should have six months of concentrated
combat training grappling training
brazilian submission training so that
they don't have to go to their tool belt
whether it's a taser
whether it's a firearm or if you're a
silly beat cop in the uh untouchables or
all of the uk
a belly club right spin it around i
think that they shouldn't have to so
they need better training
but here is actually we have a clip of
um
them showing that this was the training
for the police officers he didn't just
do this rogue
the officers were holding floyd in what
attached mpd training materials call
maximal restraint technique the training
materials include a photograph of an
officer with his knee on the suspect's
neck
this comes despite mpd chief madera
arredondo repeatedly saying after the
death of george floyd
that officers are not trained to put
their needs that's that's the problem
with the law
same training materials say the suspect
should be turned to his side in what's
called a recovery position
which the body camera transcript shows
lane asked a second time
this time chauvin didn't answer right
now the issue there is it doesn't say
how long until you roll someone over to
the recovery position right
either usually historical the precedent
that's been set here is
once someone stops struggling once
someone is no longer a threat
now that being said as far as i disagree
with you and that's okay i just want you
on shaving being an [ __ ] because i
think
all the way up until this point he was
incredibly lenient
uh that's why we showed it before this
stream the 20-minute arrest
there have been officers who have been
shot in far
less unruly scenarios i think we have a
shorter montage here
of them trying to get him into the car
keep in mind george floyd says his mom
just died she died two years ago
he's not putting his hands up when they
ask he's asking them to put the air on
if they have heated seats in a sunroof
and they're saying we're going to stay
there with you we're going to open the
window
i can't breathe calm down saying i can't
breathe the second they cuff him
okay just to be clear again we were told
that he said i can't breathe once he was
on the ground and the cop ignored him
now that's the very first thing he went
to to try and avoid being cuffed here's
a montage
we're trying to get out of the street
here so you don't get hit by a car that
was it we got him could you please crack
it for me please
i will please stay with me man thank you
i'll roll
so here's the thing someone passed a
fake bill in there oh
we come over here he starts grabbing for
the keys and all that stuff
in the hood starts getting here not
showing us his hands i don't know what's
going on so you're coming out of the car
so just hang tight right here
so this is important because yeah right
away he's saying i'm not going they talk
about why don't they de-escalate
i'm not going to shoot you please put
your hands up over here hey i'm going to
stay with you
i'll stay with you all the sources by
the way will be available at
lotterycredit.com including the
20-minute tape
i'm going to stay with you i'll open the
windows don't shoot me i'm not going to
shoot you
okay i'm not going to shoot you please
comply and then he has two
perfectly reasonable interactions with
the other two people involved
yeah so i think that yes at this point
then it gets increasingly violent
the guy increasingly resists resists
arrest and
he asked to be put on the ground yeah
well and i think and then he didn't roll
him over that's the issue there which
again now we're at the point with there
isn't malicious intent
on the outset this wasn't just random
racial profiling
he was non-compliant and then with a
rule book
that they're used in their training to
kneel on the neck and turn them over he
didn't do the last part
okay what's what kind of a charge should
that be right that's right
well the what isn't the last thing
called the
the resurrect though i mean isn't that
the cover recovery recovery sorry
resurrect resurrection very quickly
that's that's what that was jesus christ
jesus yes
it's almost easter put your hand through
my side man
but it is true that's the recovery
position it feels like that's the most
important of all the positions to put
somebody in to keep them alive well i
don't think so
it's not called the recovery position to
keep people alive it's called the
recovery position because now you've
subdued
the the perpetrator right whatever it is
you've got them on their side now you
can get them up and into the car
right you're you're getting them into
it's not saying oh you're about to kill
them but you roll them over so that you
don't kill them i think
i think what you're trying to say is the
cashiers are just taking the 20.
[Laughter]
no i just i just said all of the context
to this matters and i think somebody no
it does
their opinions not you dave but a number
of people form their opinions no dave
just on the last five minutes
of the video that we saw kneeling on the
neck not understanding
like never having dealt with somebody
who's been on drugs i've heard story
after story after story of somebody on
pcp
lane even asked he's like hey do you
guys think he's on pcp or something
yeah those guys have strength that you
have no idea where it comes from
oh yeah tons of bottles i think we have
a hunch well it's a pcb
yeah well basically it makes you get
naked and it
gives you the strength of 10 minutes
yeah i had a friend who was a police
officer one of my jujitsu coaches and
there was a guy on pcp and what he did
was he stripped down naked
he crapped in his hand covered himself
in and said he wants to catch me and he
was a new uh police officer so they said
all right you're up
that's you buddy which actually is
pretty clever well they sprayed it
first yeah
the context matters but my question so
now that we've watched all of this right
and we understand the context we
understand that there was training we
understand that this officer knew this
man we understand this officer knew this
man had a violent history i understand
that he was very accommodating for 20
minutes
did it warrant the most violent unruly
mostly peaceful riots that we've ever
seen in our lives keep in mind
all of these riots over the course of
the summer and by the way remember the
covet ticker disappeared for two months
for a little bit
it was all predicated on george floyd
and derek chavin
here's uh here's a little reminder in
case you've forgotten
peaceful little uh it's mostly peace
peaceful little car lot fire
that's a cool thing to yell hey by the
way at least that's not a government
building
update on uh on the trial right now the
judge i guess
he had walked away and he said that they
would get things started up again at 10
30 eastern
10 30 eastern so that means in five
minutes yeah yeah okay all right so
that's not bad
uh good thank you so i have a little bit
of time 112 minneapolis officers filed
disability claims due to ptsd
uh just it doesn't matter because just a
minneapolis doesn't matter because it
wasn't uh
wasn't the capital so uh minneapolis had
to spend remember they wanted to defund
the police yeah right and they
spent 6.4 million dollars to recruit new
police officers ow i don't know why
anyone would become a coptic no
no oh i can't imagine i can't imagine no
who signs up for it in minneapolis like
you would have to pay them like you know
500 grand a year and be like all right
here you go here's your new benefits
yeah minneapolis kenosha yeah how are
you going to have any police officers
no oh no no especially if you get rid of
qualified immunity because now you can
be sued for anything yeah
you want to know what it's like it's
like being a doctor and operating on
somebody and they die and there's
nothing you did wrong but you're getting
sued anyway it's just this is we're at
the point where everything is so
politicized keep in mind that this was
from the obama administration this is
overlay j if you're looking for it
um this is a 2011 report that black
males aged 14 to 24 commit homicide at
37
times the rate of the normal population
and here's the thing is it because of
melanin
no despite what elmo says okay well
elmo's pretty sure
they look like frank yankers puppets
it's not because they're black why it's
because i i've got to tell you this too
this ties into the whole voting law
thing in georgia
um i can't think of anything more racist
i really can't i was just
sort of sitting there with my weapon
hold on a second where they're saying
this is voter suppression voter
suppression voter suppression with
voting
this is how the left views black
americans and it really
is sad they're saying hey black
americans
can't afford to get id okay well you
know what it's free
uh well they can't get to the dmv uh
well uh uh
okay they can sign up for it online
black people don't know how to use the
internet how racist
is that [ __ ] when you think about it
that was biden it said
yeah so that's the issue here it's the
low expectations okay the judge here is
talking with his turtle shell mask get
his hands up
and follow the instructions so let me
know when it's
doing the vanilla ice wrap from secret
of the use yes
go charvin go shove and go go go
you're free and then suge knight dangles
them from a balcony they should have
suge knight
in there just for no reason no just
because
but there's black people can't get voter
id they don't know how to use the
internet
and in this case it's well they commit
37 times a crime because they're black
they commit that because police officers
are more likely to shoot them we know
none of that is true
and they think that some of this will be
fixed with 200
more per pupil spending an education
look black lives matter has decided
to uh destroy they said that the nuclear
family is a symbol of white patriarchy
well
you know what at one point it was
actually a symbol of black culture
in this country because black families
had a lower divorce rate
they had more children and fewer
divorces than what and guess what
they were doing better familially as far
as family at that point you know
literacy rates were increasing at a
faster rate than after
the lyndon johnson rules um it's
for them to now say that's a symbol of
white privilege is very
clear that there has been a goal to
systematically pull up the thread that
allows for self-governance in this
country and that is the family unit
and considering that a huge percentage a
majority of young black men grow up
without a dad that's the single greatest
indicator that you have
but no one can say it and this is the
problem when all of this is based on a
lie
guess what you will hurt the black
community more
when your biggest mount when your
biggest spokespeople your biggest
mouthpiece black lives matter says
we want fewer dads in the house yeah
absolutely well it's hard to have dads
when kamala keeps arresting them
well that's true or banging them yeah
one of the two we always hear education
is a silver bullet man it will solve
well that's there's some truth to that
but the silver bullet is actually having
two parents in the household yes
right a mother and a father now if
somebody dies that's a different
situation it still ends up being tough
because you still have one parent
but two people in the household a mom
and a dad where is that silver bullet
the majority of the time of the day
right they're with their friends well it
doesn't matter exactly right so the
problem that teachers say you have with
education is that you it's not about
what they learn during the day it's what
their parents reinforce at night they
just come back
the same the next day and have to learn
the same stuff over again and so
that does play out right we're not
trying to solve the actual problems
we're trying to say we can fix it with a
band-aid
and never address the real issue and if
you say it like you just said
you're racist for pointing that out no
you're not racist for
in any way i think for stating facts but
there is a part of it where
but there is an issue with black people
and the police it dates back
very very far and there is with the
whites and the police like i've said
i've actually been beaten by cops
yeah you didn't deserve that no that was
too far but
that was one cop who was a dick yeah but
you're right i forgot that you're uh
you're you're growing up story is a
walking lifetime movie
yes just him being pushed on a flight of
stairs yes and at the end i beat up
meredith baxter bernie
yeah you ain't gonna you're not gonna
have this baby
yeah he thought i was a lady i'm like
i'm pregnant
but you're 100 right dave right there
has been a problem in the in the
policing in
in some urban areas that are
statistically highly black areas that
white cops have done horrific
things that is absolutely true right you
have to deal with that
but the only way to deal with that is to
deal with reality right now we have
thrown kind of this fake outrage in this
correct
straw man that we've built that
everybody's attacking that won't solve
the problem we have a high
we have a higher percentage of
minorities and black people in the
police force than the general population
so
yeah so no yeah but they're all uncle
tom the tide is turning for sure
no no this has been happening for a very
long time no i i agree like it was
turning for a long time so i think we're
pretty much there but there is this
passed down fear that people have when
you see george floyd right there he's
afraid of that guy he may not be afraid
of the other three
yeah but he has a legitimate fear of
that guy now he wasn't afraid for the
first 20 minutes
i think he was i think anybody being
stopped by police is going to be afraid
well
okay but that's the point it's like what
do you listen you're never having
you're high you're not complying with
the police i'm saying i'm not going to
shoot you i'm not no look i'll put you
in the car i'll leave the air on the
guy's high as a kite
maybe you should i think he should be
concerned if he's
breaking the law and he has a rap
cheater you should be and i'm not saying
you're wrong about that
if you're concerned here's what you do
you turn the car off you take the keys
out of the ignition you put your hands
on the steering wheel and you ask the
officer officer what can i do
just you you comply you those are the
things now i get if you're
i do that when i'm asking a police
officer for direction yeah
i go hey excuse me officer ha ha ha
hands
here hey do you know how to get to the
nearest dunkin donuts because i want to
get those comments stop at starbucks the
time of day i say i'm reaching for my
phone
i'm reaching for my phone i'm reaching
because it's my insurance is on there
now what did i say the thing about my
phone is
it's shaped like a gun blam blam blam
and they let me go and you say blam yeah
then they realize it's just you joking
and they're like ah crowded well they
mainly realize it's me white
yeah yeah it's that white privilege card
yeah that's what it is yeah once i roll
down the tin windows they're like you
can go
oh we thought you were somebody right
here they give me six cookies
that's the part is there's always been
an issue with some police officers in
power yeah of course that is just a fact
and i think that's something that does
have to be acknowledged in this
situation and he looks like a guy
and because of his rap sheet as well
that would abuse his power
in my opinion i didn't see that in this
tape i see it at the very end where he
didn't roll him over
yeah and i wonder how much the audience
played into that right he's well
from the street side now i understand at
that point you have to take into
consideration if you put a guy in
recovery position
right that also means that he can get
out he can move
and he's surrounded by people now who
are yelling and recording and that can
become a very dangerous choice but his
attention is now distracted
he's not just thinking about the person
that he's holding down he's thinking
about a a group of people that are
starting to get a little bit more tense
and a little bit now
they had understandable reason to say
hey he's not moving get off of him
i think both i think to dave's point
both were afraid of each other because
how big is uh george is he six foot
seven
six six six six huge uh
known violent offender i mean look i
don't want to say sociopathic but
someone who
robs a woman aims cases the joint with
his buddies
jams a pistol into her stomach when her
toddler is in the room
and continues living a life of crime
that's the kind of person who you have
to take seriously and you know the
officers knew that when they pulled up
on him
and then i think he's probably afraid of
shaving because they knew each other and
he he knew that he was a police officer
and
in some cases i you know i i've read
about i haven't seen extensive proof
that chavan has been this monster that
they make him out to be as far as
abusing his power
and i just don't see it in this tape i
really don't i see it as an unfortunate
situation
that happened and again it certainly
isn't justification for the statistics
but that
for a lie regarding the statistics of
crime
between officers and black americans and
we're not having an honest dialogue but
i do think
something that has helped us a silver
lining some progress and we make baby
steps along the way
is of course in minneapolis the
wonderful george floyd
autonomous zone where multiple bodies
have been found people have been killed
because police are not allowed in so
baby steps
see they have to walk around the
autonomous zone and uh there was a young
uh
black person who was shot in there and
then uh
died because they had to get body out i
don't think you should just get to have
an autonomous zone i'm gonna throw it up
it makes no sense that you can just take
over before
i remember when i first heard about it
someone had to explain i'm like what do
you mean what do you mean
autonomous zone like yeah they just took
it over and they're not letting anyone
in like
well you can do what you can do
depending on that i mean
yeah downtown seattle's just peter topia
from family guy you're like what
happened
like you're not allowed to just have
this well yeah we are and the cops like
oh i'm sorry
like listen there's a rapper here with a
40 000 grand from the government he's
our
king
yeah what did it take a couple of weeks
for that thing to fall apart well yeah
not before our interns were chased off
with guns rightfully so in quarter black
garrett and even brendan
i just like when the guy's car is stolen
and he's like somebody called the police
it's like you really don't get this do
you yeah
i think there's something with the
sequence of events and disconnect here
raz this is the extremes though that's
the problem is we're looking at the
extremes and the extremes are
controlling the narrative
i don't think we're looking at extremes
i think we're looking at one side which
is a
stream that's controlling the narrative
right now i mean there's true police
being defunded
right the left is not saying hey we need
to uh we need to
i guess weaken the police union so that
bad police officers can be hard because
they can't do that right
they're saying hey defund the police and
that actually means defund the police
yes or remove qualified immunity
no chokeholds which i vehemently
disagree with i guess just hit someone
mercilessly with a baton or use a taser
that doesn't work on someone with pcp
if you are committing a if someone is
committing a serious violent crime let's
say you were down in your luck you're
hungry you're stealing you commit armed
robbery and you know that you deserve to
go to prison
you would pray that you get choked
unconscious and wake up in the paddy
wagon that's the most
gentle way to go as someone who's been
choked out
many times i still wear a leather helmet
when i'm not doing the show
i wear a full mask
which by the way i think actually so the
george floyd we went down to chas you
guys know that in seattle
we sent our team we broadcast live from
there for a while uh
we weren't able to do a whole show from
there but we have do we have him
so actually live on location our on the
ground correspondent
at the minneapolis autonomous zone is
thomas finnegan
[Music]
okay mr finnegan i know things are
heating up there with uh the trial
underway uh can you hear me tell us
what's going on uh on the ground good
morning stephen
i'm in minneapolis at george floyd
square the new autonomous so
we know that yeah yeah what's going on
uh let's see
there's some gentlemen over there i'll
go ask them some questions well i don't
think that's not
that's not we don't have the insurance
writer tom tom thomas
no uh what's this white [ __ ] no
camera
yeah i don't
[Music]
well we'll check back in with him later
brave mr finnegan
he's a tough reporter it seems we should
see this coming yeah
uh they're going another opening
statement he's uh still addressing the
jurors it looks like
all right let's see mr turtle shell mask
addressing the jurors again
the hashtag is crowder shaving stream
because i'm not on the twitter
uh and uh you can just send all your
tweets to at dave landau
i know he's like land out dave please we
can't hear what he's saying right now
but
i imagine he's saying your lives are
over if you don't convict this fellow
yes
yeah is nancy pelosi in the back there
uh opening segments how is that going
like do people understand what
airborne particles are no no ladies and
gentlemen of the jury
good morning my name is jerry blackwell
and
i apologize for talking to you through
this plex hilarious
it's probably the least of the gifts
that the pandemic has given us
you're going to learn in this case i bet
you
a lot of vaccinations about what it
means to be a public servant
and to have the honor of wearing this
badge
it's a small badge that carries with it
a large responsibility and a large
accountability
to the public what does it stand for
it represents the very motto of the
minneapolis police department
my toe to protect with courage to serve
with compassion
but it also represents the essence
of the minneapolis police department
approach to the use of force
against its citizens when appropriate
the sanctity of sanctity of life and the
protection of the public
shall be the cornerstones of the
minneapolis police department
maybe he's a conservative
compassion sanctity of life cornerstones
and that little badge is worn right over
the officer's heart he's already a
better lawyer i'm sorry but you're also
going to learn that the officers take
an oath when they become police officers
they take a note that i will enforce the
law courteously and appropriately
and as you will learn as applies to this
case
never employing a necessary force or
violence
and not only that
i recognize the badge of my office some
people
put it up full screen every now and then
on me and bottom line accept it as a
publisher i don't think
that copyright to be held so long as i
am true to the ethics of police service
symbol of public faith ethics to police
service
sanctity of life all of this matters
tremendously to this case
because you will learn that on may 25th
of 2020 mr derek chavin
betrayed this badge
when he used excessive and unreasonable
force
upon the body of mr george floyd
that he put his knees upon his neck and
his back
which is in the training grinding and
crushing him
until the very breath no legend
gentlemen until the very life
we're squeezed out of them no no that's
not true we can bring it up it wasn't
squeezed out of them look
we have the coroner's report it wasn't
asphyxiation that's not what happened
he he died because of an over there was
an overdose of drugs in his system
he had coveted difficulty breathing
there is no evidence none whatsoever
that it came from the knee on the neck
now
that's not pleasant i'm sure it doesn't
help but
that would not cause asphyxiation that
wouldn't choke somebody
and it wouldn't cause diaphragmatic
asphyxiation this is also something that
i know pretty well
right there was a guy who used to be
called kavaka in jiu jitsu he would do a
move that would compress your diaphragm
and you couldn't breathe
okay that is something that can be done
that would be done from a knee on the
belly or in the solar plexus
the coroner's report shows that that is
not
what happened okay so we need to be
clear about that did he die from the
knee on the neck
no but do you think it could be argued
because he was on drugs that he could
have been riled up by that situation
he could have been but considering that
this is a technique that's been used by
the department for
years and it hasn't happened with anyone
else we would have to say okay
what's the outlier here it's the copious
amounts of drugs that we know cause
fatal overdoses right and
go ahead yeah and we need to go back
yeah sorry but hold that thought we are
bringing this case this prosecution of
this against mr chavin
for the excessive force being applied
onto body
of mr george floyd for engaging in
behavior that was eminently dangerous
in the force that he applied without
regard for its impact
on the life of mr george floyd
so let's begin by focusing then on what
we will disagree with without regard
tried to get him in the car
told him he wouldn't shoot him offered
to get him in the car with
cooled seats air conditioning windows
open and a sunroof and george floyd
requested that he'd be put on the ground
at which point he used a police protocol
to ensure that the man could not leave
now i don't think it's a good protocol
right but the idea with total disregard
would you say
hey get in the car i'll turn on that's
not total disregard
no hey man come on please get in the car
that's not total disregard you can watch
the full
tape if george floyd had died at home
which is very possible
it would have been ruled an overdose
because of the obscene amounts of
fentanyl
methamphetamine in his system combined
with a heart condition
and covid i don't believe it was total
disregard for the first 19 minutes
i just think it's weird that that mr
chauvin is there with a notepad drawing
penises
it's just a weird time right yeah any
other time when you got a drum when you
got a drama
he says i'll probably die this way i'm
through
i'm through they're going to kill me
they're going to kill me man
now hold on a second does he say i can't
breathe 27 times in the ground
or are they including the i can't
breathe keep in mind we have the tape
where george floyd is in the car getting
out and they put cuffs on him before
they carry him to the cop car
i can't breathe man i can't breathe are
they including that one 27 times
yeah or or trying to get him into the
back i can't breathe needs to be tossed
out as
entirely irrelevant because he said it
immediately and by the way
it's very common for people to do that
with police officers because they
believe it's a
get out of a rest free card yeah javin
was sorry uh
floyd was saying it does 27 times
include that can we find that can we
fact check that because we
counted dozens of times you will hear
his words further apart
you will see that his respiration gets
shallower and shallower
and finally stops when he speaks his
last words
i can't breathe and once
we have his final words you'll see that
for roughly 53 seconds
he is completely silent and virtually
motionless with just sporadic movements
you're going to learn those sporadic
movements matter greatly in this case
because what they reflect
uh mr floyd was no longer breathing when
he's making these uh
movements you will learn about something
in this case called an anoxic
seizure it is the body's automatic
reflex when
breathing has stopped due to oxygen
deprivation we'll be able to point out
to you when you'll see
the involuntary movements from mr floyd
that are part of an inoxide seizure not
only that
you're going to learn about something
that's called agonal breathing
when the heart is stopped when blood is
no longer coursing through the veins
you will hear the body gasp as an
involuntary reflex
see all this by the way is designed to
try and connect the dots that
right he was asphyxiated by the cop no
it wasn't the report shows that he
wasn't
blood stopped coursing through his veins
because of shoving that's not what
happened
you can you can he panicked sure you can
say the guy was uh
shaving was had his knee on him for too
long sure but the idea
that he died because of shaving no and i
you know what we can do i'll have you
put your knee on my neck here in this
studio right afterwards
okay again it's is it uncomfortable it
is uncomfortable but the reason they
teach it to police officers is because
it wouldn't asphyxiate someone this is a
guy who was on fentanyl who was on meth
this is a guy who was very heavy had a
pre-existing heart condition
and had coveted anywhere else in the
media right now fauci would be touting
it as a covid death
let's be clear about that they're trying
to connect the dots so you think that
all of these right now all all of these
issues all of these twit
the issues of twitching the issue of
blood flow stopping that that is
directly attributable
to the knee on the neck just like they
want you to think that 27 times i can't
breathe
is directly attributable to shavings
action it's not
it's not because he was saying it when
he was in his car when he was out of
both cars and when they were trying to
get him in the cop car
so we need to be clear here don't
connect dots where they don't connect
i do think uh and again it's just my
opinion but shaving is
is guilty there but at the same time how
comfortable are we supposed to make
criminals this is what i don't
understand
you're committing a crime that results
as a punishment getting arrested is a
punishment
right it is par i mean i guess it's not
the punishment yet the punishment the
whole point is to get
the point is not punishment is to remove
you as a threat from society right and
at that point
he refused to get in the car they
couldn't remove him yeah but how
comfortable are you supposed to make
somebody during that
it just doesn't make any sense to me
like if you're doing everything that you
can
what how much farther do you have to
take it i i don't know
if you look at the new laws they're
proposing it's you can't subdue them at
all you have to let them go
well that's a good idea yeah oh well
they should just do whatever well if
they have kovid you have to let them go
just like georgia they want you to be
able to fight two officers tase them in
the face and still go
right and you're right anything could
happen called the cove of death
right move the lifeless body of george
floyd onto the gurney
only then does mr chavin let us get up
and you'll see him drag
mr floyd's body and unceremoniously
uh cast it onto oh come on how is he
gonna pick up a guy two hundred and what
is he 260 270 pounds
yeah there wasn't a nearby florence of
his
his enemy onto this that's not like
roadkill
like me with the snapping turtle where i
told you that story where i
there was a snapping turtle in the road
i'll tell you this really quickly
there's a snapping turtle the rest has
happened to me twice and i don't i i
i don't want to kill it but the thing is
get up turn around
and snapped my stick in half yeah and i
knew off the road there's a little
pond a little river so there was a
construction area where there was like
two by fours kind of stakes
so what i finally did was i got the
snapping turtle because it kept
turning around trying to get aggressive
with me so i turned my back to the pond
i scooped it in like highland games i
scooped it and whipped it
back into the pond probably went about
50 feet in the air
i heard it plunge and it landed on a
giant face
you made it no you said this to seven
twice twice
you've done this twice with snapping
turtle where are you going yeah
i'll show you it's not funny hanging out
they're all around they're all around
are you gonna drive me to the woods and
you're like yeah we're just gonna go see
snapping turtles hey what's with the
shallow grave this is
you don't need a deep one dave no dave
you have to dig six feet to find them
turtles
just look down there there's a snapping
turtle down there
in the grave yeah yeah yeah yeah some
people calling it a grave
put some lavender in there take it take
a sniff do you like lavender
oh that's nice lavender with current
minneapolis police department training
uh oh but it is what did he say what's
that
consistent with training it is
consistent with training it is that is
consistent must be evaluated
i have a problem with the training you
guys should have a problem with the
training i do
but your problem is with the training
let's be clear
shavon didn't go rogue by putting his
knee on his neck he was taught that
and police officers get mad at me most
of our police officers
when it comes to physical altercations
outside of these weapons are incompetent
are completely incompetent and that
needs to be fixed it's also why
we shouldn't have weak female officers
out in the field what do you think a
weak female officer is going to do when
you get nailed in the head with a snare
drum by antifa
and you're five foot two and you have to
do a plank because you can't do the knee
tuck for the pt requirement
i want big strong capable men who don't
have to use their weapons or a sturdy
girl
yeah a buck make some woman nick yeah i
want gsp
george saint pierre is the perfect
policeman he's a welterweight yeah but
he's fine it doesn't matter
yeah i want sly stallone's ex that hooks
up with flavor flav
i want frank stallone oh yeah i'm gonna
go take it back
no everybody we should listen to this
statement because it's uh you know
landmark case and uh what have you who
was handcuffed
who was not resisting that there's no
calls to use that
force in the first place you're going to
hear nothing happens unless
he requests to be put on the ground
which he did
again we showed you guys the video for
people you can rewind it and come back
here
live while you're watching right now he
requested
to be put on the ground because he
didn't want to be in an open windowed
air-conditioned car the other lawyer
should be all
in white and then there should be
ceiling fans on and he should speak with
the southern accent
while wiping himself with a handkerchief
he's a try
you're also going to learn about another
very important uh policy
in the minneapolis police department
that's a corporate oh you know what here
let's play this really quickly please
yeah
just because they said uh floyd said i
can't breathe 27 times
i've got to believe that includes the
many many times where he tried to use it
to get out of being arrested for a crime
uh i've got to imagine because we have a
clip of him saying i can't breathe long
before he was even restrained here you
go
in fairness he did initially say i can't
choke he was looking for uh
private judo lessons but by the way do
you think he would have calmed down in
the backseat of that car
if that's your argument that if you
could just calm them down it would have
been fine by putting
he would have flipped that block you
ever tried to calm someone down on
fentanyl and methamphetamine no
and they can't breathe it proves
surprisingly difficult fentanyl
they're positively intervention surely
in your custody is in your care you're
going to learn that when mr floyd was
unconscious
uh that when he was breathless when he
did not have a pulse
that there was a duty to have
administered care to let up and get up
exactly i knew you you listened to
minneapolis police commander
katie blackwell no relation to my
knowledge
but you will hear from katie blackwell
and she's going to tell you about the
training that mr chavin received
uh you're going to hear that he was a
veteran on the minneapolis police
department
for 19 years had been trained in cpr
multiple times at the time
and you'll be able to see for yourself
okay really quickly the reason
important cpr was also because of
another lie well let's have the control
room uh the edit bay bring this up
they called the paramedics they did they
called the paramedics
the paramedics performed the cpr yeah
one of the houses did as well
right that's what i'm saying one of the
offices the officers uh one of the
officers performed cpr as well
yeah and then they waited for the
paramedics so they called the pyramid
that was a lie too right why was this
man there when no medical assistance was
called
it was why was no medical assistance
provided it was so what they are trying
to make you think right now is
no medical assistance was called it was
and no one helped no
shaving didn't perform the cpr because
another officer did
what if the other officer is better what
if he just recently had his refresher
course well
it doesn't matter if chavin did it it
matters
if he was provided the proper medical
attention
which he was but the media lied about
that too but it also matters when
they knew that he needed it did they
think he was just passed out because he
was on drugs and they were finally able
to control him or did they know and they
may if they knew early and didn't
provide it then that's where this case
comes in
right but they're they're assuming that
right now well he just said chava didn't
provide
cpr right yeah i'm putting my lips on
another man's lips
i ain't that kind of guy man i'm just
gonna do that
give him cpr that's gay
chief at the time he's the chief today
he is going to tell you that mr chavin's
conduct
was not consistent with minneapolis
police department
training it was not but is that the same
guy who lied about it earlier
policy was not you know if mahoney
wasn't joking around all the time the
police would take their jobs a lot more
seriously
he'd be very decisive that this was
excessive force so ultimately ladies and
gentlemen what was this all about
in the first place here we go here it is
well you're going to learn that it was
about
a counterfeit 20 bill used at a
convenience store
that's all you will not hear any
evidence that mr floyd knew that it was
fake
or did it on purpose you will learn
from witnesses we will call that the
police officers could have written him a
ticket and let the court sort it out
nope they couldn't have again go to the
clip they couldn't have because he
wasn't complying the moment they pulled
him over
started screaming don't shoot me my
mom's dead and they said well
reaching for the reaching erratically in
the car i said keep your hands where i
can see him and he didn't and that
escalated look
maybe this time it wasn't a violent
crime like george floyd committed many
many times in the past
not saying he deserves to die not saying
that at all but let's be honest many
many violent crimes in the past
a rap sheet maybe that's not what
happened maybe they could have given a
ticket for a counterfeit 20 assuming
that he didn't even know and he wasn't
high on drugs
but that is irrelevant because then the
time frame changes from
erratic non-compliance
for 10 minutes with the officers it's no
longer about the counterfeit 20.
they didn't put him on the ground
because of counterfeit 20. they put him
on the ground because he yelled
and he screamed and he was non-compliant
for 10 minutes
and he requested to be put on the ground
has nothing to do at that point with the
counterfeit 20. if you're pulled over
for going 10 over the speeding limit and
the officer says let me see your id
and you start screaming about you're not
that kind of guy and you don't give him
your id
and you're reaching out and you're
reaching for something other than your
id and your officer said the officers
say get out of the car
and then you say that you can't breathe
you're not that kind of guy and they say
we're going to need to get you into the
car while we
check your plate and you refuse to and
your request to be put on the ground
it's no longer about your speeding
ticket
for 9 minutes and 29 seconds
uh was the 20 counterfeit for sure
because i know it was a suspicion of a
counterfeit
we're going to prove it ladies and
gentlemen i don't know that we know that
i don't it doesn't really matter
no it doesn't but i i'm curious yeah i
don't think
i don't think he knew i mean if i'm
being honest he's just a guy in drugs
who probably
runs around with people i think he was
an upstanding citizen who would be
positively
uh offended to see that someone would
counterfeit a bill responsible yeah
training
that's what i was saying
around first aid coming to the care
about sucks we'll bring in a number of
policies it does
and it's so many levels it sucks on so
many levels but what
really sucks is that black people are
going to be more vulnerable because of
these riots in the defunding police
based on a false narrative and you're
seeing them try to construct reconstruct
it
at every turn he said he couldn't
breathe he said he couldn't breathe
long before he requested being put in
his stomach this is just what we've seen
so far
he didn't know it was a counterfeit 20.
has nothing to do with the counterfeit
20 it has over 10
it has to do with over 10 minutes of
non-compliance he was asphyxiated nope
the coroner report shows that he was not
as fixated there was no damage to the
spinal cord what's
these things aren't true it wasn't a
part of police training it absolutely
was a part of police training
now it doesn't mean that there's no
accountability or culpability
but you have to then sentence based on
the evidence
not based on signs what between walgreen
burnings yeah
exactly you guys remember this happened
to a white guy in dallas too right
yes virtually the exact same scenario
yes
well it happens all the time who died of
fentanyl no who died after
saying he couldn't breathe and cops were
subduing him and had him on the ground
same kind of situation but did did you
see the riots and burning of walgreens
then
no it didn't happen no i saw it i stole
that
problem then it was just oh it was an
accident apparently there are a few
extra five-fingered discounts at lane
bryant
so oh yeah the range rears its head in
one form well this doesn't actually need
ten fingers for that stuff
i think this guy can't go to the
if you want to see we have that body cam
footage and it's not shoving but it's
the other it's the rookie
cop who's doing cpr oh okay let's show
this so this is the rookie cop was doing
cpr before the paramedics got there who
were called
it's it's uh it's with it's inside the
oh it's inside there
the paramedic oh okay well let's show it
in the ambulance
so the cops were giving him cpr yeah
i feel like it's a bit late you want me
doing just impressions
yes i mean they got him in right and
started doing it right away
yeah that's true i i just don't like
looking at it no i know no one like all
right that's enough there
token allen he's he's he's uh okinawan
so i think the whole situation just
sucks and this is what happens when
a bunch of people maybe who don't
necessarily know what they're doing
one's on drugs poor training whatever
everything just i don't think that a cop
would willingly with all those cameras
on him necessarily do this but i do
think he is responsible for it it's just
how i feel
well what is it but what is he murdered
before specifically i don't think he's
responsible for murder i think he's
responsible for manslaughter though
that's a pretty high bar though i mean
you're talking about putting somebody
away for what 20.
never seen me 15 to 20 years i don't
know what the
manslaughter uh deal is wait that's a
lie i don't either yeah
oh i thought it was a high bar well
that's probably why you're so good at
limbo
when you do bath when you're really far
up there you and cuomo they lower the
rim when you limbo and they raise the
bar
uh just so you know i can dunk on a five
foot rim
very good for you
especially if you can face palm a
toddler out of the way while he does it
i'm
i'm five six i could not dunk on a five
seven rim
i'm not kidding no way all right let's
uh let's go back to the statement i'm
going to show you in a moment
one of the videos that you're going to
see uh in this trial just to kind of tee
up for you
uh what will be the essence of what we
will be focused on
in the trial uh i need to tell you head
ahead show the full video that the video
is graphic that it can be difficult so
to be clear second degree manslaughter
the definition is by the person's
culpable negligence whereby the person
creates an unreasonable risk and
consciously takes chances of causing
death or great bodily harm to another so
shaving would have to have displayed
culpable
negligence and he was considering that
he was following the police department
protocol
it's pretty tough again going by the law
you know it would mean that he had to
consciously create a scenario where he
no knew that he could kill somebody well
we've created a scenario where the sins
of everything in the past are now riding
on this trial
and the potential of extreme violence
which is not what a
a system uh our system of law is based
on it's based on evidence well our
system of law is based on systemic
racism and patriarchy so
of course without that yeah some of the
judges are [ __ ] you don't learn that at
your luaus
yeah i do i bo i we get a pig we put an
apple in its mouth
and by pig i mean cop oh wow
right have you seen the little piggies
in the starched white shirts
to be able to pick up candy and snacks
when they came up always have clean
shirts
to play around
john lennon you're responsible for
countless dead cops he really is
he was shot by a patriot he was oh jesus
the first responder who tried to
intervene
i joke he was really the one that broke
up the beatles though he was everybody
what do you expect from a self-avowed
communist who has four rolls-royces in
the upper west side he's really an idiot
he's a man of the people he also abused
his son who walks around
that neighborhood also in in the 70s you
go for a stroll you're going to get shot
so anything i don't know anything about
it
coming in uh to talk with you nobody got
ringgo and so
they come from the broad spectrum of
humanity tragedy uh different races
i'll put my knee on ring there's neck
yeah older people
younger people just for us all stars
i'll show you what it feels like to be
under the sea
oh see the pun is that they saw
something
that was shocking to them that was
disturbing to them and it made them stop
and take note stop and take note
they tried to first it doesn't seem long
i'm sorry that just seems
brutally long with their voices put a
knee on a man's neck uh
they tried to interject to exhort it's
here's the thing it's if it's taught as
a control position
that's not long at all it's not taught
as an asphyxiation so to ch
in other words if you choke someone for
a minute they're dead however anyone
who's ever been
in uh let's take jiu jitsu matches
because this is where positions like
this occur all the time
my language it's ten minutes a ten
minute match and it's very common
for someone to be in a control position
far more uncomfortable than that
for ten minutes and into overtime so a
control position
held for 10 minutes is not long at all
as a matter of fact you're supposed to
be able to hold it indefinitely so if it
was taught
to the police department as a con a
subdue and control position
that's not long if it was taught as an
asphyxiation
which it was not that song people need
to understand that now i don't think
that it's a good control position i
think it's stupid to be taught to police
officers and i think that pamphlet was
probably written by some guy who gave
himself a black belt and some [ __ ]
martial art that doesn't exist
and he gave him a position where frankly
uh george floyd could have
tipped him off literally tipped him off
of him at any point in time
however it was taught as a control
position
and that's why it matters sort of like
one and i'm not saying this as an insult
but as someone who has
had to deal with control positions right
half of what we learn in jiu jitsu and
wrestling is how to establish control
how to escape control 10 minutes is not
long 10 minutes is the minimal
expectation
of what you are supposed to be able to
hold until backup shows up
that's different between a submission or
an incapacitating move for example
tasing someone hitting them with a night
stick choking them
that's not what was taught and this is
the problem when you haven't
when you have an a group of people
watching it who go well that looks bad
look there are certain things that look
bad that are not painful at all for
example being choked unconscious that's
why we choked
audio wage here on the show so that
people know what it's like
if they taught police officers this is
how you control someone which is what
they did
that's a problem with the training okay
they're showing a video well the guy
whose name
who wrote the bill i believe his name is
ray and he did have a black belt in ray
jitsu very good
rayquan
my name's briana
if this is all you see but by the way
they're not choking him there either
that's important to note
they're not choking him there right that
is not expelling the air from him
no it does it's is it bad training yes
but that
is not a choke but if that's all you see
you assume that that's because of he's
saying he can't breathe because of that
if you don't see that he was saying it
before if you don't see that he was
saying it when he was getting put in the
police car he was like
hey let's bring back up the clip for
people who have bring back up the clip
of him saying i can't breathe
uh well before well before that happened
bring that up show that clip again
i can't choke i can't breathe again that
is not commensurate with
the level of force being used he was
acting erratically and irrationally so
it go
it's the boy who cried wolf at a certain
point when you've been saying i can't
breathe by their own account 27 times
now people go hold on a second he's also
been violent in the past
is this an excuse to try and get a jump
on us which happens all
the time and if their weight is
distributed properly and this is why i
say dave this matters
if your weight is not on their diaphragm
you're not restricting their breathing
these police officers likely had to have
look
look at that he just moved his head he
just lifted his head and moved his head
rotated it did you see that
no it doesn't mean something didn't
happen that was wrong so i'm not saying
that i'm saying that he didn't choke him
out by doing this he didn't
suffocate him by doing this right right
no i i better ask and
delineate that because what they're
doing right now is they're showing the
jury this and saying look he's able to
move
his head i could this is the issue here
too is someone again people out there
who are college wrestlers high school
wrestlers
people who do jiu jitsu come on comment
send me your chats at mug club lotto
dot com mug club you know that when
someone has a lock
on you when someone gets you in a side
control position when someone gets you
in a cradle
you cannot move your head and lift it
around you are
pinned it's intentionally uncomfortable
and they're not trying to do that
hey by the way can we also have them
pull up the clip of where he asked to be
put
who said it's why you don't do drugs
kids i think it was shelvin who said it
and that's my that's my theory and that
bothers me though of course it does
that's not
it's not taking it seriously well no it
shows neglect i think well hold on dave
if if
this position has been done countless
times before they've had it done to
themselves in training they know what it
does to you
and so if they're thinking okay i'm
doing a position i've done countless
times it's been done to me
it's uncomfortable i can breathe it's
totally fine it's not gonna hurt anybody
then you can take it like that and say
okay this guy's just being erratic
you have to take all of this context it
doesn't mean he didn't make a mistake by
not turning him over it doesn't mean
that he made a mistake here
his mistake is focusing on the crowd and
not on george floyd
and i don't think it's a crowd's fault
they're scared for a guy it's his fault
for saying yeah
guys y'all shouldn't do drugs by the way
there are plenty of entrances especially
in these these riots if the crowd starts
filming and then
beat the hell i think oh of course yeah
no i'm not oh of course yeah that means
all the time well i mean it's the same
as mel gibson's wife
filming him and getting them all riled
up and then hitting and you will blow me
in the hot tub because i deserve it like
i love how he feels he needs
justification
but i love this like he's sold but i
will give you one more channel one more
chance she's like really
oh that's what i wanted one more one
more chance do you mean it father
you made a promise
oh i do look forward to the jacuzzi for
our fellaishic aquatic rum
yes i've told everyone i can't wait
you've sincerely earned your treatsies
he did though by being mel gibson he's
like you like this house yeah me too
yeah i'm gonna pull this out i'll be in
the hot dog
he has a hot tub yeah just that alone
i'll get to know him
by the way how scared do you think
george floyd is of of chauvin if he said
don't leave me right well i'm sorry that
that just doesn't
those two things don't add up to me
you're you're scared for your life
against this one police officer who's
apparently
going to do something terrible to you
and you're like don't leave me man don't
leave me don't leave me
yeah you don't say that to somebody
you're scared of right
so all of this matters but look at all
that blood
that's p oh and that's terrible and
that's the gut-wrenching part of this
yeah is that piss for real look at him i
believe so
well that would that would indicate fear
yeah
you pee yourself if you're on drugs too
right or death well
i mean you could be dead i mean a lot of
people do it just by drinking
yeah i do it when i slow dance
is he breathing right jesus sorry
there's a lot of christians okay
check his paws bro bro check his paws
bro
i'm just looking at one human being to
another in an isolated situation
and that's it's it's horrible it's hard
for me to
not look at him like even though what
he's done in the past
obviously is horrible this exact moment
is the issue yeah but it's not exactly
it's not about what he's done right
it's just this moment i i just don't i
think this is too much
does that mean that shelvin is guilty of
a crime punishable by
15 years in prison that's the question
that we're going to the question that i
and the honest answer is yes by looking
at the video and my gut feeling i just
feel that way but
if this is how they're trained yeah
you're right there's something to look
at
right yeah and i think that that's why
you want the legal system to be about
the facts
and not yeah and not a fear of nation
burning right right yeah exactly i mean
otherwise you end up with oj well it's
not even well nation burning party
like imagine if you're a juror that
votes to not convict i mean if the
police was there
sprinkling blood all over the place like
for oj right
that was really the problem was the lapd
was super racist
mark furman was like i've never used the
n-word on tape eleven thousand times
it wasn't a great time for lapd this was
not a great time for you yeah i'm not a
good
oj did it no he definitely oh he totally
did it but you didn't have to fake it
that's my point right
you have to go we need to add evidence
to the mountain of evidence
yeah and so my my problem dave with this
again this is heartbreaking when i watch
this
my gut hurts of course yes it does it's
hard how does your heart not break yeah
yeah
so but that's the thing like you need to
make sure that if you're going to make a
judgment call on what happened you see
the whole context of course the the
state showing just this
is trying to get you to see this and
have your heart break and never be able
to think of it any other way
and the guys that are coming behind him
in the defense and saying look but all
of this that led up to it
matters all of this that happened
matters joy it's possible
that he would have been so erratic in
the back of that car that he could have
died on the way to the police yeah
we have the other day to come to that
medical examiner
but it is possible that he could have
survived attack and was
and couldn't breathe even then but you
know what though yeah but you can't base
police protocol on
not subduing someone if they have a
panic attack oh i agree because i've you
know i've had this happen actually my
dad will tell you the first time anyone
who's ever done jiu jitsu i've just
gotten into a position
you've gotten the first time it happens
i've had people people the very first
ufc
the very first you watch mma now right
and you watch it you see people okay
exchanging positions on the ground the
very first fight that ever happened was
joyce gracie 170 pounds against a boxer
named art jefferson he came in with one
boxing glove and you know what happened
hoyce gracie took art jimerson down and
he simply got to a position we know his
mount meaning
he got on top of him yeah that's all
and you just see the one boxing glove
happened he had a panic attack and he
tapped yeah nowadays that's just getting
started
someone will escape there'll be there'll
be some kind of a sweep rotating
positions because people know what's
going on
anyone who goes into their first will
panic this is a professional boxer
who simply found himself on his back and
he panicked and tapped and you can hear
the story he's told the stress
i feel like i couldn't breathe i felt
like a fish out of water i panicked
it's supposed to make you feel powerless
so that you don't fight and get violent
um
let's show the clip really quickly of
him asking to be put on the ground
because
that is relevant he is only on the
ground by request and
keep in mind the protocol for keeping
someone controlled on the ground
is very different from a police car that
with doors that cannot be opened from
the inside that are childproof right
that's the point they tried to get him
in the car many many times he said i
can't breathe in the car
so put me on the ground here's his
request
he's struggling hard right there they're
trying to push him in the car
and you say i'm gonna get on the ground
and now they're saying okay
let's get him out and get him on the
ground
[Music]
there's somewhere i can't breathe
somewhere i can't believe you hear the
guy say hey he's getting a heart attack
get him in the
gutter
i can't breathe there is no weight on
him right now
none whatsoever they're trying to lift
him up and saying he can't breathe is he
saying put me on the ground
yes yeah earlier he said
put me anywhere on the ground
here come on i i couldn't tell if it was
about the ground no no
because i watched the video a few times
but it's hard to
understand with all the yeah no he's
saying put me on the ground
yeah he's saying that he wants to go on
the ground and he's refusing to get in
the car
well listen there's a reason that people
put put uh uh suspects put assailants
put criminals in cop cars because it's
the safest place
both for them and for the people to whom
they could do damage
in the community someone on fentanyl and
meth
someone who's committed multiple violent
crimes in the past a threat to the
community
and so you do treat that person
differently yeah well and if
it comes down to siobhan uh shoveling
now i'm almost going to do what judah
made a mistake like if that's the deal
like he didn't roll him over and it was
a mistake it wasn't
intentional let's just assume right
let's assume that's the case
would he not also be just as responsible
because george floyd could you could say
well if you had just gotten in the car
if you they had
they had you there if you had just
gotten in the car
the rest of this now it's not like
someone took his gun out and shot him
that that wouldn't have mattered at that
point well that's different that
wouldn't have been that it would you
couldn't say to george floyd you know in
retrospect saying hey you if you just
got in the car right
but in this case if that's all that they
prove is that he made a mistake
by not rolling him over don't you have
to do it
but wouldn't chauvin then be dead and
floyd would be on trial for manslaughter
i mean if you if if sheldon was the one
that died in this no no no that's not
what i was saying oh
i think you were saying if shavan pulled
out his gun yeah it's not like after he
refused to get in the car shoved and
pulled out his gun and shot him
no it's obvious like that chauvin had
committed a crime but if all we can say
is that he
he was trained poorly with something
that should never have been done and he
made a mistake towards the end not
rolling over
let me ask you this dave yeah and you
watch that all that in the car okay and
the pullover do you think that any of
that is excessive
the force in the car well the them
getting him out of his car which by the
way
the irony he's not lost on me that he
can't get in a car because he's
claustrophobic when he was driving in a
compact
yeah um he's he's it seems that it's a
it's a
fear of being inside police cars not
it's police claustrophobia
claustrophobia let me ask you this do
you think that it was like that right
there in
the car was excessive no uh
based on his history the number of
police surrounding him now if it was
anybody else
not based on his history i would be a
little surprised because that does seem
like a lot of people on one just
for an initial stop but well no i think
it was two people it was two people and
then there were more which is now the
standard
right like one has to be yeah uh no i
don't
because i'm asking because you can't get
them in the car
i understand that they can't get them in
the car i understand that they're
fighting with them i don't think that i
think it's excessive on both their parts
right or not excessive at all if you're
going to i guess to put it that way
right my my thing is when he's on the
ground
yeah and he's got his knee on his neck
for nine and a half minutes
that is excessive the rest of it i don't
think i think they're just
trying to do their let me ask you this
you're a police officer this is
this is something so let's walk through
this and then i want to go back to his
statements here and i'm just
i'm just playing no i i appreciate it
don't take this person because i
understand questions you know so many
people
have people yeah i really was trying to
say david
he's very clear about the fact that he's
more moderate and i understand where
he's lining up here
i think that he should have been turned
over as well however let's walk this
through
you pull a man over well i think funding
police and writing is stupid yes of
course
of course that's a whole nother thing
you're what when people say i'm
reasonably moderate
it doesn't exist anymore there's like
you and no one morons um
but uh okay pull them over guy is
erratic
guy's saying his mom is dead guy's not
putting his hands above his head
saying don't shoot me you say i won't
shoot you okay
now you try and take him over the cop
car he's screaming that i can't breathe
okay he refuses to get in the cop car
at this point you refuse you have
multiple officers come in after you've
made accommodation after you've made
accommodations you've rolled down the
window
he says i can't breathe i'm gonna have a
heart attack i won't get in the cop car
okay you can
and at this point keep in mind the
officers are not able to control him
that's all the officers trying to get
him into the car
kicking them off pushing he's bigger and
stronger they have no ability to control
him he refuses says
i will not get in the car okay so now he
says put me on the ground
you have no choice because you can't
deal with this guy's strength to get him
in the cop car
you saw that okay now you've gotten a
man who's resisted arrest who has a
history of violent criminal behavior
who seems to be on drugs and erratic on
the ground outside of a cop car
and you need to wait until backup comes
up what do you need to do
you need to control them on the ground
how have you been taught to do it
so what else does someone do the point
is
oh it's it's excessive sure how long did
it take for backup to earth how long did
it take for the paramedics to arrive
that's how long you have to control
someone on the ground my point is
it's a horrible control technique the
liability should be with the police
department teaching that right now yeah
well that's not racial profiling it's
bad physical training
but this man is on the ground you
haven't been able to control him with
handcuffs
in the car multiple officers you now
have a waiting period
how do you control him they use the only
tools that were available to them
to control him well and defunding the
police and emts in a lot of those
neighborhoods with
especially that's a really hard job to
being an emt
and having to get there in all those
different places in time yeah it does
matter how long it took them to get
there and in those neighborhoods
we all know people have bled out because
they can't get their services in time
to even help anyone right yeah so
there's a lot of things that yeah
can come into play of why that's a
tragedy i just don't know
how anything i don't know how
differently it could have played out
short of the training but do you think
that's the only training for that
situation
i guess is my question it's it's what
they're trying to do to control someone
on the ground
cuffed that's strange to me though
strange
it's strange to me that they were
teaching police officers with
taekwondo for hand-to-hand combat for 30
years when they had a 50-pound utility
belt
they don't have very good hand-to-hand
training at all
right we've had cops come into our
schools regularly even when i was a
philanthropy and they just they
they have no idea how to deal with
someone physically they're good with
guns
they're good with sticks they're good
with tasers it is we need
reform of police training first police
training needs to be better first and
that requires funding sorry let's go and
listen to the
request take away the money yes first
then and then try here
and a wallet where there was a lot of
pulse you'll hear from
a number of experts on the stand that
putting a man in the prone position with
handcuffs behind his back
somebody on his neck and back pressing
down on him
for nine minutes and 29 seconds is
enough to take a life
you will hear that also but that's not
what took his life no
you're also going to hear from other
experts who will point to
autopsy no evidence of strangulation or
asphyxiation lethal amounts of drugs
could it figuratively maybe but we know
it took his life
it was an asphyxiation ladies and
gentlemen the road rash
on the shoulders from where it's been
pressed into the pavement from the
weight on top that's stripped off layers
of the skin
the same thing you don't get road rash
from being pressed you get road rash
from moving and straight to resistance
to his nose when he pressed his face
into the paper
to try to get room to breathe ladies and
gentlemen no his head was turned
right back if you put me on a road naked
and you lay
gerald dave quarter black garrett
okinawan toolman everyone here on top of
me i will not have road rage
it's not possible just press into you
road rash i'll give you it requires
movement friction which requires what
some space to move yes what he just said
i think was a lie though
he just said you'll see nose imprints
where he pushed his face into the ground
so that he could create room to breathe
and i was like actually we have video of
his head being to the side
his head to the side and his head then
coming up off the ground
and moving the other side yeah i don't
know about a lawyer line but
and this this is important the cops say
this if you can talk you can breathe
yeah well that's true but then to calm
down they're telling him like hey calm
down calm down calm down
that's like when you're wrestling with
your brother though or your rock hard
uncle and you're like i can't breathe
because that you don't know the words
to explain that i'm losing air to get to
i'm going to get in trouble for that
to get to that recovery position they
have to know that they have you subdued
and then they can roll you over now i
know that that's a tough situation being
especially if you well it's just the
verbalization of
saying i'm starting to feel as if i'm
losing air
is not that's why i can't breathe is
just what you say it's it's almost a
childlike response yeah yeah but he's
just or a dishonest response
that's clearly what was going on here in
other words the reason i can't breathe
if he was saying
all right look hey i don't like cars can
you put me on the ground
okay all right i'm gonna go and then
goes oh man i can't breathe can you ease
up very very different from
all right man put your hands behind my
back i can't breathe i can't breathe i
ain't that kind of guy my mom's dead i
can't breathe i can't breathe hey look
get in the back i can't i'm not getting
kind of got it i have no new don't leave
me don't leave me don't let me i can't
breathe look look
cool on the ground put me on the ground
put me under at no point did he stop
from the moment he was pulled out of his
car saying i can't breathe
and that's why it was treated just like
the other 27 times if i can't breathe
when they knew he could breathe
right and it just shows you that there
are other possible explanations for what
happened other than
of course a white guy who's a cop killed
a black guy which is what the media has
been telling us
let's all i don't think it would say
he's guilty let's say he's guilty for
manslaughter okay
i don't believe that he is you and i
disagree on that because i of the legal
definition i don't think it meets it
we also have to allow for the fact that
everything
being carried out up until this point
was kosher and let's just say we
disagree in the last nine minutes
that it isn't due to racism that it's
due to a guy who's
fed up with someone high off his mind
being a difficult
dick and wanting to go home to his wife
that night
maybe or maybe he had a bad day it was
like all right this is all right
okay now i'm just gonna keep you here
until the paramedics get here it doesn't
necessarily
mean it has anything to do with race
even if you allow for the possibility of
manslaughter
and the pivot to this is racial by the
way other officers there minor there's
one guy who's a minor is it two or
minorities
at least one's black and one's
well back then that's when asians didn't
matter but now they're the newest
victim now there's black lives matter
asian lives matter which is careful
careful almost get into all that matter
carefully
you add one more what are what are we a
white supremacist nation
oh okay okay that guy's oh yeah those
two guys are white for sure
he's in some movies right he was looking
like
dave he was he was there when they
dropped the bomb totally a joke
come on we got it i got a light in the
mood here all right okay sorry we need
to hear this man uh talk no
nothing wrong with this responsive uh he
was calling out for his life
he was struggling he was not passing out
now you're also going to hear from a
forensic pathologist
dr lindsey thomas and what she does as a
forensic pathologist
she studies body tissues on autopsy
to try to determine the cause and manner
of death she did this over 35-year
career as a foreign doctor over that
period of time she had done that
well well she's a pa okay well that's
good enough
of the 87 she's a nurse and we needed
something a little sexy
needed something a little sexy
determined oj had the kardashians and
[ __ ]
oh boy of others
she's semi-retired now and uh works as a
consultant still in the field
of pathology she was one of the persons
who helped to train
the current hennepin county medical
examiner dr andrew baker when he was
just getting started out in forensic
pathology
so had it been here's where doctor is
that the examiner who said there was
no proof of asphyxiation
so andrew baker bigger
baker from dr baker maybe he should
stick to making gay cakes
when he list
homicide now i want to explain to you
that when he uses homicide
it's not the way that we use it here in
the courtroom when the medic examiner
says homicide it simply means that the
person died
at the hands of another is what that
means
and i will show you what list that's
chosen from in just a minute and dr
thomas will come in and testify about
that but it means that he died at the
hands of another
but you'll also learn
that he listed the cause of death
cardiopulmonary
arrest complicating law enforcement
subdual
restraint and neck compression now
i'm going to translate that into english
and you'll hear this from dr thomas
wait are they trying to say this this is
from a separate separate person
a separate person because this is not
the they just mentioned they see they
just conflate it the hennepin county
autopsy did not show that
they were saying that this person
trained this person trained that person
yeah so there's much better party they
must be right so they're trying but they
do you see what he just did there he
tried to make it seem as though
the count is somehow connected to the
county whereas the county said no yeah
you have that collage right here that
there was phenomenal in a system
a lethal amount of fentanyl meth was it
uh was it methamphetamine or crack
cocaine
methamphetamine 19 nanograms per
milliliter the autopsy revealed that
no physical findings support a diagnosis
of traumatic asphyxiation or
strangulation that's that's the official
from the county
okay these people get other people
doctor shopped and found someone else to
look at that okay what he's quoting from
is a press release yeah recording from
there's a press room not so they didn't
actually examine the body
uh i don't know i don't know if she
examined the body post
okay or what but they're they're quoting
from a press release trying to make it
seem like well no this is the official
here's what they're saying she trained
the hennepin county
examiner right and she believes this but
the hennepin county examiner the
official examination
the autopsy report says the person
actually saw the body the person who
actually did the examination he was
trained by a lady doctor and we're
taking this all seriously
this whole thing should be thrown out
he brings up about horrible i'm just
come on guys
you're you're you're doing all right
hold on a second so how's it going or
disease
today car accident can be an accidental
death
suicide homicide which is when they
chose that at the hands of another
thank you or undetermined that if you
can't tell which it is or what it is
you indicate undetermined and here you
will learn that dr andrew baker
and dr thomas determined amongst these
possible
manners of death it wasn't natural not
accidental
not suicide not undetermined
it was homicide death at the hands of
another
but that's not all that dr thomas is
going to tell you
she's going to tell you something about
the limitations
of pathology that is looking at the
tissue the name of the person is
baker so there's actually they're saying
baker and thomas both came to this
conclusion
that's what he just said yeah but right
now i'm reading this right here let's
uh hennepin county medical examiner
conducted more
uh may 26 2020. full report is pending
but
the autopsy revealed no physical
findings that support a diagnosis of
traumatic asphyxia or strangulation
mr floyd had under floyd had underlying
health conditions including coronary
artery disease and hypersensitive heart
disease
the combined effects of mr floyd being
restrained by the police his underlying
health conditions
and any potential intoxicants in his
system likely contributed to his death
and then the next note right here that i
have and you can bring this up i believe
says
andrew baker said that if mr floyd had
been found dead in his home or anywhere
else and there were no other concerning
factors he would conclude that it was an
overdose death
so in other words there are these
contributing factors and what they're
having to say
is that it wasn't an accident like
slipping in the tub so you have to
categorize it
it should have been one of those five
categories right
i mean it seems like you said homicide
means death
involved he's saying at the hands of
another involving someone else
right yeah and now how what that means
is difficult
for you know law they're not saying that
legally he's responsible for that death
right just saying
that in this case but yeah i guess well
and if
you weren't on fentanyl and you died
because of that that's one thing but
yeah
there's so many factors that could be
into play to
create that bomb yeah that it i mean
it's
put it this way technically if i was on
a bunch of fentanyl and methamphetamine
and i went to the bathroom came out and
you went
boo and i dropped dead from a heart
attack right that would have to be
medically listed as a homicide right
doesn't mean you're guilty of murder or
manslaughter maybe he's tried
i have and i have something he pulls the
old slip the fentanyl and
methamphetamine in my cheerios trick
wait a second yeah am i again am i
really superhuman
able to leave buildings in a in a single
boundary is this just
dave's old fentanyl and meth and the
cheerios trick yep
and for some reason we have a lot of
ghost costumes here
yeah that is strange now by the way just
just to confirm just to make sure
everybody's on the same page here if if
shoving is kneeling on this guy's neck
thinking all right finally i get to take
my revenge on the black man i'm not
getting up until he's dead we would all
say fry him right
yes of course right well yeah that
heartbeat but
so that's what the media is saying that
this is why this happened right we're
saying well hold on there doesn't seem
to be any evidence of that there still
doesn't seem to be any evidence of that
yeah his wife was miss minnesota
good for him really yeah i forgot about
that that's not exactly miss argentina
or venezuela
no no no name the talent pool's a little
more [ __ ] basically
half of that talent pool is pulled from
the 4-h club well that's true
if it's right i believe she's an of
asian descent
and miss minnesota not to be confused
with miss michigan my right hand right
crowd
no they can get it yeah we've all dated
her
i don't know right i'm a lefty i go you
reverse european
sorry no one deserved that
and i just died from that joke he's
claustrophobic
i'm i'm responsible oh wait a second
this is important my way into the squad
car
and he starts trying to count one two up
the manhattan
shove him into the car with the
handcuffs on and you'll see
how he freaks out from that
uh you hear him saying i can't breathe
in the back of the squad car and we will
show you
in the back of the squad car where mr
chavin at one point had his hands around
mr floyd's neck
his squad car and another his arm and
elbow around his neck with mr floyd's
head here when he'll pull him out of the
squad car putting him on the ground in
the prone position
that couldn't be left what are you gonna
grab when he's flopping like a fish in
the car
do people understand that between a
choke and a headlock
look headlocks in high school wrestling
legal
chokes are not a headlock is how you
grab someone it's like you grab your
brother you're pulling someone out of
the car because you can't get him into
the car
this guy is making a case against
himself right now and also floyd's six
for 223 pounds like you're supposed to
like grab him by the pinky
well that's how you say somebody who's
drowning you put your arm around their
neck and under their arm and pull them
to save yes
it's used did he say around his neck and
under his arm even sanders arm just
around his neck
with five grown men armed police
officers present
do you want them to shoot him that way
they're armed is that true
what i didn't see a chokehold in the car
i didn't die
you'll see no it's not he didn't even
say chokehold he said he had his arm
around his
neck oh so in other words he grabbed him
and pulled him out of the car
but he's trying to conflate look he was
already because in other words he's
saying that he was saying he couldn't
breathe because of that but we already
showed you footage where george floyd
was saying i can't breathe when he was
sitting george floyd was in this exact
position
sitting saying i can't breathe i can't
breathe i can't breathe it has nothing
to do
with a headlock to place him by request
uh on the ground and it has nothing to
do
with the reason he was saying i can't
breathe the control position on the
ground
he was saying it when there was no
reason to believe it this is a
so anyone who's watched this video the
full tape
he just made a case against himself this
attorney right now
this is important to note he just made
the case against himself saying
and you can see george floyd saying i
can't breathe in the car
so people who haven't seen this tape are
going to go wait a second right
i thought he only said i can't breathe
when he was on the ground
he was saying i can't breathe the entire
time that's
the point not available
it looks like he's got an arm under can
we see it can we he he's got like an arm
under floyd's arm but there's nothing
showing that that's not headlock
right there's an underhook and then when
he pulls him out he doesn't have
he doesn't have a headlock let me see so
that's not a headlock
yeah is this the shaving body camera or
which one is shot
i think chauvin has his arm around him
yeah i think yeah this is the other guy
lane i think
i think that was his point yeah okay
well it's honestly no headlock no no no
no no no headlock he's not hurt
no you're right he's escorting him out
it's not i don't know
i don't like this dangerous behavior
putting the knee on the neck
the knee on the back for nine minutes
and 29 seconds without regard for mr
floyd's life
we're going to ask that you find him
guilty a murder in the second degree
murder in the third degree so let me
bring this up again
the bar that needs to be passed for
murder i have these definitions written
in front of me so murder third degree
if he wants to charge a murder third
degree uh defined whoever without intent
to affect the death of any person causes
the death of another by
perpetrating an act eminently dangerous
to others and evincing a depraved mind
without regard for human life as guilty
of murder in the third degree
so he would have had to cause the death
which again is not from the
toxicology report um do we have murder
in the second degree
yeah defense yeah we have the defense
argument now
talking about doubt but for purposes
of my remarks this morning i want to
talk about
reason and common sense and how that
applies to the evidence
that you're about to see during the
course of this trial
reason is an idea that wholly permeates
our law
our legal system and it forms the
foundation and you will see
and hear that repeatedly throughout the
course it's funny on big bang theory
what would a reasonable police officer
do
what is a reasonable use of force
what would a reasonable person do in his
or her most
important affairs what is a reasonable
doubt
as such reason dictates and necessitates
how the evidence must be looked at and
analyzed in every single case
and common sense is exactly that it's
common sense
common sense tells you that there are
always two sides
why are we worrying about governments
yeah suffice covet can't go over seven
feet
this whole thing is just unreal every
bit of this courtroom and everything
happening
in other words common sense is the
application of sound
judgment downstairs open mic or tie oh
it really is isn't it
and that's what this case is ultimately
about it's about the
evidence in this case the evidence that
you will see
in this case during this trial it is
i agree with council for this road it is
nothing
more than that there is no political or
social cause in this courtroom
there is other people ready to beat your
ass outside that courtroom
yeah 29 seconds in this case you will
learn
that the evidence has been collected
broadly and expansively minnesota bureau
of criminal apprehension employed nearly
50
case agents analysts and technicians
to investigate this case the federal
bureau of investigation
included at least 28 additional agents
in their investigation were all the
other cops fired these
agents you know yeah i know that two of
them were i don't know
that all the last ones to come on the
scene maybe not but i think right you're
right like the two that were what we're
around trying to play
okay i knew something happened but i
wasn't sure including the officers who
responded to the scene after mr floyd
was brought to
the hospital they were they interviewed
members of the minneapolis police
department command staff
they interviewed officers who oversee
training and
policy making decisions within the
minneapolis police department
they have interviewed nearly 200
civilian witnesses
in this case some of these witnesses saw
the entire incident
some who saw a portion of the incident
many who saw nothing and some who
had some piece of information to give to
the officers and others you stopped
stepping
to and away from the microphone like i
am yeah
needs to go home right now
you never go full [ __ ] by the way it
looks like all the cops were
fired all of them were fired yeah okay
four right four i knew that two were and
then i yeah six total ended up there so
i think the last two were five
i believe this case called the bait
stamp number
the bait stamp system is a way for
lawyers to keep track of the case to
make sure that we are working from the
same set of documents
the same set of evidence to
preserve the integrity of the
investigation you will learn
that we are approaching 50 000 bait
stamped items
so this case is clearly more than about
nine minutes and 29 seconds
go ahead go pee go urinate dave because
i i do too
after during jury selection the witness
switched off this case
near 400 people make it quicker you'll
need glasses
to analyze and organize this evidence
i suggest that you let common sense and
reason
guide you i propose
that every witness you will hear from
and every piece of evidence that you
will see or hear during this trial
can be assigned to one of four basic
locations
cup foods mercedes-benz
squad 320 and hennepin so here's the
challenge too though that he's making
the
the challenge with his case the first
man came out and even though it wasn't
particularly factually based
wasn't it it was entirely an appeal to
emotion oh yeah and this guy's saying
i'm just going
with the evidence he's got to do both
yeah he's got to do both
so far i'm i'm picking vinnie while they
were there
going with this guy mr floyd's
ex-girlfriend shawanda hill
and he offered her a ride
you will hear from chris martin who is
the store clerk at
cup foods chris martin ah mr martin
observed mr floyd shows up
he watches body language he
interacted with mr floyd
and the cop was all yellow and mr floyd
was under the
influence of something well one of them
was you can't call him that you will see
the actual video from inside cup foods
mr floyd did use a counterfeit twenty
dollar bill to purchase a pack of
cigarettes
mr martin realized this and first along
with another one of his co-workers named
nabil walter
went outside to the car where mr floyd
mr hall and miss hill were sitting
mr martin asked mr floyd to come in and
either
buy the cigarettes exchange or return
the cigarettes
and you will hear from mr martin that mr
hall
and mr floyd refused
you will hear that a short time later mr
martin went
back to the car a second time
went back to ask them again please come
inside
give us the money or return the
cigarettes
and that second time again mr floyd
refused
i no i wasn't fully aware that that
interaction which
is kind of important because that's
george floyd being a dick
to a local member of the community who
just doesn't want to be fleece for a
pack of cigarettes
right during that doesn't mean doesn't
mean he deserved nothing
of course not but again people trying
painters oh this is a guy who had a
prior criminal history a long time ago
but like
you know like the tookie williams thing
yeah now is really look when people talk
about we need to sit we need to serve
and protect our own community
george floyd was ripping off shop owners
and the shop owner was giving him an out
saying look please hey look man this is
fake
yeah give me give me the cigarettes back
or pay for it
because he can call the police
immediately yeah
he was giving him a chance they faced
parking southbound in the northbound
lane of chicago avenue
and were directed by store employees
immediately
to the second location the mercedes-benz
during this trial you will hear evidence
of what happened
in the mercedes-benz in the 20 to 30
minutes
prior to the police arriving you will
hear from
mr floyd's friends shawanda hill and
maurice hall
this will include evidence that while
they were in the car
mr floyd consumed what were thought to
be
two percocet pills mr floyd's
friends will explain that mr floyd fell
asleep in the car
and that they couldn't wake him up oh
that's right i forgot the toxicology
report had oxycodone as well right the
police might be coming because now the
star was coming out
it's just sort of you take the you know
you take these you take the
the marquee drug which is fentanyl but
oxycodone for most is
pretty potent yeah to come and pick her
up
because it couldn't keep mr floyd awake
at 809 pm officers lane and king
approached the vehicle
and officer lane approached the driver
side of the vehicle
and officer king approached the
passenger side
during the course of this trial you will
see so not only was it a counterfeit
20. i didn't we didn't know this because
i think some of this is new evidence
not only was it a counterfeit 20 but the
guy who gave them the pack of cigarettes
for counterfeit 20 knew it
and asked them kindly to hey please give
me back my cigarettes
or pay with real money george floyd blew
him off went to his car the shopkeeper
from cup foods went back to him said
please just give me back the cigarettes
or pay me for the cigarettes so george
floyd knew that it was counterfeit and
he had two outs from the shopkeeper
before the police were notified
so blue and counterfeit 20 you really do
have cameras in your bathroom
and handcuffed i'm sorry i'm over here
officers and mr floyd i didn't know that
though
i don't think he's a counterfeiter guy
though no i don't think he's but he had
that it just shows
complete disregard for members of the
community where it's like you're like
please man just
give me back my cigarettes or give me
real money i have to make a living
two times and that's why this guy got
pissed at approximately well the guy
would get pissed i think he
notified notified the police notified
the police after giving him two times
trying to not bring the cops into it
yeah
in response to the scene to assist
officers king and lane
and he helps in detaining the passengers
you will see officer chang's body worn
camera and you will hear his
interactions
this becomes important is guy he
practices
no because what you will learn is that
when an officer responds to what is
sometimes a mortal kombat 3 character
was it i thought so showed up johnny
chang
greater and more serious event
you will see surveillance videos near
squad 320 from a local business called
the dragon walk
that capture the actions and reactions
of all
of everyone present at that location
dragon walk in
that's an ethiopian restaurant i'm
guessing further concealment
controlled substances during the course
of the investigation
two search warrants were executed on the
mercedes-benz
the first on may 27th of 2020
the second several months later on
december 9th of 2020.
now see that is important folks though
the defense said you will see and hear
everything that these officers and mr
floyd said to each other
that's important it's very different
from the prosecution who said look at
this clip
look at this clip we're going to show
you this clip you're going to hear from
this person who isn't officially with
the county but who trained them and who
says that it could have maybe been this
right now this guy said full and
complete transparency now
that's not proof in and of itself but i
will say this
when you have two parties in a
disagreement and one
is opting for complete and total
transparency and one is fighting against
that
that is usually a red flag when someone
is
when there is one person evol involved
with this
conflict altercation this case two
lawyers demanding full transparency
and one requesting no that it's more
opaque
right away you should take note the
evidence will show that as
officers king and lane escorted mr floyd
yeah if you're willing to show
every word being said charles mcmillian
i mean it is definitely worth listening
to
and he was encouraging mr floyd to
cooperate with the officers
the evidence will show that mr floyd and
the officers began to struggle
as they attempted to get him in the
squad car
and you will learn that officers derek
chauvin and his partner tu tau
arrived to assist officers king and lane
pronounced
guys racist man upon their arrival
the first thing that officer chauvin
sees is officers king and lane
struggling with mr floyd
mr mr chauvin asked the artist
king's first name rodney
i was going to say it's like there's all
these cops
were they all named after the mr roger
like the mr rogers convention
first was king tuesday to the scene
followed by lady lane
prince wednesday prince wednesday yeah
wasn't it king tuesday and prince
wednesday i think so
49 and then the ron paul muppet looking
lady weighs 223 pounds
you will learn that because of this this
intersection at 38th and chicago is
considered a high crime area
getting fried in saul's it's called the
most
and can surveil the entire intersection
tuesday wasn't really what mattered his
name was king either way
if it works yeah it's true from afar
there's a reason okinawans were rated
worse sense of humor on the planet
that's something isn't it back and forth
why do they carry a grudge
they do so much so that it catches the
attention of the 911 dispatcher jenna
scurry
this was not an easy struggle
as the struggle continues you will see
and hear both what mr floyd was saying
to the officers
and the officers makes me a little
uneasy that uh
his partner there is writing down notes
like he's surprised
yeah oh we're talking about that so much
oh
is that what i'm here for i think that's
showing i was about to say i think
that's
strange officer oh is this a nice sorry
keep in mind i'm looking at this right
now like
he's just penning off how many stitches
he's got in his anus so far
guys i need a four-letter word for
screwed yeah anybody
officer king was placed he's just
playing hangman
and officer lane was at the feet
and you will see and hear them continue
to struggle with mr floyd as he's
what did you just think of that you
wouldn't say what you just thought of
something that you didn't want to say
oh i said a few i thought of a few
things
i thought i'll just say i thought of a
word that would be funny that he was
using to play hangman
that's your own interpretation you're
going oh it starts with a c not that
word okay
you will see in here the conversation i
just write that sound
no that's not the joke but that is also
funny
there's a movie with matt damon and
greg kinnear where he's like what are
the twins yeah it's supposed to be
stuck on you yeah and it's like i love
how you know the name of the movie but
you didn't want to reference because you
you're slightly ashamed
i made a poster of me and you well my
friend steve did
as the twins that i put up the other day
i'm not ashamed well i can't see it
because i can't get on twitter
oh i know but uh
it's uh he's like uh like something
about like what would a woman be
agitated in the part of his
curse and he's like oh i was way off
there are cars stopping that's what i
thought with hangman
and him playing scrabble and then i i
made a joke that just
well it could have gone the other way
they could have yeah well you know what
either way there'll be a write-up
well yeah we can look forward to what's
that stupid magazine
that doesn't matter takes everything out
of context
[Applause]
we have stacks of in the the bathroom
of the use of force and this will
ultimately become one of the i also have
in magazine it's when you just stay in
the closet
to answer these questions the bureau of
criminal apprehension the evidence will
show that the bureau of
criminal apprehension investigated the
minneapolis police department's training
and policies
you will learn about things such as the
authorized use of force
proportionality of force excited
delirium
defensive tactics including prone
handcuffing
neck restraints maximal restraint
technique the swarm technique
you will learn about rapidly evolving
situations
and the minneapolis police department's
decision-making model
you will learn about crowd control
medical intervention
de-escalation procedural justice crisis
intervention
and the human right right now someone in
the jury is going oh
pack me with a spoon this is the worst
couldn't start the powerpoint and they
took away my sidekick
[Music]
and you will learn hey don't forget i
think we have an update from thomas
smith
oh yeah really quick oh you know what is
he there still the course yeah i think
he still looks okay so hold on let's ch
before we uh continue with this uh
because we don't know how much longer
i'm getting word yeah the thomas
finnegan is still in the george floyd
autonomous zone in minneapolis
uh on the ground uh let's check in with
thomas finnegan
[Applause]
okay thomas thomas what's going on there
the autonomous zone
[Applause]
thomas
he'll be fine let's go back to the guy
we can only
let's go back to the guy behind to flex
the glass yeah final location
how hilarious would it be if the bailiff
just just ran up and cross checked
the glass then the bailiff has to stand
in there for
two minutes looking all sad and pathetic
yeah officers called for paramedics all
right since you guys both did i have
i really have to people go ahead hold on
i'm coming out don't come out
hey dave i have a question for you yes
sir who is the funny guy i'm big bang
theory
none of them i just thought he looks a
bit like johnny galicki
who was i think that's how you say it
who was uh you might know him as the
third russ in the vacation series
oh okay yeah but no uh that is a
terrible show
i don't understand oh no i do understand
why it aired for so long it's because
people like crap
yeah and people are dumb we do and we
are
i really hate that show it's the worst
it is
it should be on trial right now we
should be watching the trial of
everybody involved
the trial of chuck laurie
for creating the television that he has
except my friend billy's show they'll be
like
three yeah and they did what they refer
to as a modern go
because of the crowd they came
they picked up mr rather than attempting
to resuscitate him or treat him on the
scene
they loaded him into the ambulance and
they drove to a
location several blocks away to begin
their resuscitative efforts
and you will hear do you think he dyes
the soul patch of his beard
i feel like he does right he's like this
is a little wolf man jacket
was transported to the emergency pretty
cool guy efforts were
efforts to save mr floyd
were made and at the direction ty is
like
made of a couch like i would have worn
to my grandmother's funeral
yeah in the 90s in fact my grandmother
did wear that to her funeral
that's so sad my grandfather did around
his neck
well it wasn't his funeral's just how
they found him what pattern
what's dark the evidence will show them
that dr andrew is that woman wearing
sandals like uh birkenstocks of sorts
the only autonomous leopard
several pieces that dr baker had with
law enforcement
guilty where he discusses the cause and
manner of death
and what that actually means according
to what he saw
present in mr floyd's this is important
right here and some of this evidence is
extremely important to the final
determination
mr floyd's cause we know move
such as the blood gas test that was
shown it was taken at hcmc
that re revealed mr floyd had an
exceptional i don't even like the guy i
think there's something oh hey steve
you're gonna want to listen to this he's
talking cause of death from the original
stuff of what are we referring to
telltale signs
of asphyxiation there were no bruises to
mr floyd's neck
no telltale signs of asphyxiation his
skin or after peeling his skin back to
the muscles
beneath there was no particular
hemorrhaging
there was no evidence that mr floyd's
airflow was restricted
and he did not determine to be a
positional
or mechanical asphyxia death
at the time mr floyd was in the hospital
a femoral blood draw
was taken that blood draw was analyzed
by a lab
the results of mr floyd's there's a i
thought
there's a lot of blood in the femur
because remember when i fractured my
femur
i didn't tear my acl there was so much
blood they were concerned
and it will be important cocaine the
blood that's right
is it where your femoral artery goes
through your leg i don't know
i'm not a doctor you're not the autopsy
what's that phd you showed me before the
physical you gave me
right next
it's not a salt if you like it with dr
baker's work
so this yeah this is important because
they said someone who trained dr
baker he's talking about the actual
report dr baker's findings
and this will ultimately be another
significant battle in this trial
what was mr floyd's actual cause of
death
the evidence will show that mr floyd
died of a cardiac arrhythmia that
occurred as a result of hypertension
his coronary disease the ingestion of
methamphetamine and fentanyl
and the adrenaline throwing flowing
through his body
all of which acted to further well and
they said he'd
compromise several percocets just right
before that
at the conclusion of this evidence you
will be instructed as to the law
the elements of the offense the court
will give you detailed instructions
on what you must find to convict mr
chauvin of these charges
but when you review the actual evidence
and when you hear the law and apply
reason and common sense
there will only be one justified and
that is
to find mr chauvin not guilty
you know what's weird is that for many
people in the country that's the first
time they're hearing any of that
oh yeah absolutely of course what do you
say about
11 15 they're going to recess i want you
to keep in mind that these breaks we try
and keep as much as we can to time
but if bathroom needs and other needs uh
are important we can expand it a little
bit so he's giving himself an hour
11 15. yeah i got a lot of backpacks i
have to make a big poop
sometimes it takes a little while i have
to drop some kids off at the pool
deputy will take you back to the uh very
thorough with me
11 15. yeah 15 minute recess i i 50
minutes then what are they going to do
after this those opening statements then
what are they going to probably jump
into it
really yeah how long do you have to do
this show today i don't think we should
cover all of it because it's going to be
a long trial right it's going to be so
you guys let us know you leave in the
comments if you don't let us know no no
i'm just saying not just for today
but do people want because this is going
to go on for a while should i be
covering this every day
i think it's good to check in on this
every day because a lot of people are
going to be watching this
yeah but it's i think it was incredibly
important for him to lay it out the way
he just did he's like guys
they had they had their report and they
weren't satisfied with it
and don't think like oh it's just you
know people wanting this just remember
what was going on
protests were erupting all over the
place in that city they were threatening
to burn things down they were
threatening to burn down city hall
right if they didn't come out with this
and so immediately they're like ah crap
that report says it wasn't asphyxiation
it's probably
some kind of an overdose and now we've
got to put something else out there
otherwise this crowd is going to get
crazy
remember the political implications of
what was going on
and who stepped in well for me this is
the point
that really bothers me and look we'll
talk more about about
shaving and and george floyd and i think
we all look this is sad
this is all very sad however the point
that really sticks out to me is
when the left right now going we got to
fix these problems in america where now
it's systemically racist everywhere so
the narrative is of course cops are
racist disregard the fact that there's
there are more
black uh officers and there are uh
percentage of the population certainly
minority officers when you include
latino and black officers because they
want to
let's let's disregard that they go we
need to fix this right now and we need
to help
those in the black community okay
this is doing the all of this together
in totality is doing the exact
opposite of that that's what makes me so
sad do you know what's harming the black
community
is not officers shooting unarmed black
men like we've said it's
nine in the year 2019 versus 19 white
guys and they're over 18 times more
likely police officers to be shot by
black men than to shoot a black man
let's be really really clear black men
in this community are 37 times more
likely to commit violent crime according
to an obama report right
37 times more likely to commit violent
crime okay
why well we just skimmed over why
we always think that in these areas and
people talk about how they're close-knit
in urban communities and in black areas
and and i i think to a degree that's
probably
more true than white communities because
there's necessarily a kinship with white
people you can be white irish you can be
white italian you can be white norwegian
german you know i'm a mutt
french english irish scottish german um
but if we're drama how closely knit
those communities why do we think that
they commit
black men commit crimes at 37 times that
the violent crimes the national average
well we just saw two examples right
there in real time which are not nearly
as severe with george floyd as
jamming a pistol into the gut of a lady
while her toddler watches
but count giving a counterfeit bill to
someone in his community
a shopkeeper i don't know if the show i
don't know if the shopkeeper is
black asian but lives in that community
and was given two opportunities to do
the right thing and didn't care to
hey the guy that guy has a family to
feed that guy is actually supporting his
community by running a business and he
and by the way trying to help his
community by knowing that someone who's
likely high is a kite who gave him a
counterfeit bill which of course takes
money out of his pocket
still not wanting to alert the
authorities two times saying hey mr
floyd
this is not a real bill please and he
gave him two options
either give me money for the cigarettes
or please just give the cigarettes back
please george floyd blew him off went
back to his car he goes out to the car
before he calls the cops please man look
think of it this way i've got kids to
feed okay 20
look please just i can't this is this is
the fifth time this week the guy's
probably been held up please just look
give me the cigarettes back or pay me
the money george floyd didn't give a
[ __ ]
this happened twice before he then
popped percocet
in addition to his fentanyl and his
methamphetamine
and lying to the cops how many other
crimes do you think he committed
that day that week the issue right now
if we want to talk about improving the
quality of life for those
in the black community is we need to
talk about these behavioral patterns and
the family
unit because someone like that does not
deserve to die
but someone like that only causes harm
when they go through their life
selfishly unabashedly so
and that's not common that shouldn't be
common that shouldn't be a part of your
community
you want more people in your community
like the shopkeeper and you want more
people in your community
who join the police force than people
like george floyd
people rest assured when i say this this
is not saying
that george floyd deserved to die and
certainly not that day
we're going to hear the evidence on that
case but george floyd
the way he acted the way we know that
he's active in his life is
far more of a problem for these kinds of
communities
than policing george floyd is a problem
george floyd is a problem mugging a
woman with her children we have a rap
sheet a mile long
even just to the selfish day-to-day
having no empathy for a shopkeeper has
to feed his kids
given two opportunities to not steal
i wasn't given that opportunity i snuck
into a movie they kicked me out
right and that was because i didn't want
to pay for michael moore film so i paid
for another one i stuck into michael
moore
i was kicked out immediately anyways
it's a principle that's fair how many
how many grace crimes
does one get before you say you know
what okay
maybe we have a problem here in this
community that people feel so fine take
we talk about wall street bankers and we
talk about
capitalists and corporatists and people
taking advantage of the middle class and
they don't care
and they show well you know what okay
listen and i understand that they're
somewhat removed and it's not violent so
these people
don't get punished the way they should
certainly banks when we talk about the
bailouts i think that's criminal
but why are we not offended when a black
guy does it to a shopkeeper who he knows
on a day-to-day basis ray just
steals cigarettes and let's be real
why did he not do it why do you think
george floyd bloom because he's bigger
and stronger and probably intimidated
the guy
yeah just like mike brown do you guys
remember that knocked over a liquor
store
the day he stole the gun from officer
wilson and hit him in the head with it
you see in a pattern you think officer
wilson who specifically asked to be in
ferguson
so that he could have more interactions
and help those underprivileged there was
not a racist bone in darren wilson's
body
you think that guy's a problem or do you
think the guy mike brown who that
day committed a crime against other
members of his community
before violently assaulting an officer
is more indicative of the problem in
this community or you think it's the cop
do you think that george floyd with a
rap sheet a mile long and that
day committed a crime taking money out
of someone else's pocket
is a problem or do you think it's just
when the cops show up
we need to be able to talk about these
things if you're going to make it all
about race
cnn msnbc and racist cops if you want if
we want to have dialogues to improve
everyone's community guess what
it's not about the cops and it's not
about melanin what are you about to say
what are you doing there i think the
extreme division is certainly not the
way to handle it
i don't think the division is a way to
hit but the problem is there's no way
around it now
because immediately before the body was
cold they were talking
about because that's right that's why al
sharpton exists i mean that's why he's
there he's a racial ambulance chaser
it's why he showed up and i'll just say
it on this show
he's also a guy who hates jewish people
and has been very vocal about that and
that's perfectly acceptable no
yeah but i just don't think it's about
dividing everything in half
and that's the problem right now is we
want to just completely
look at it as these black and white
issues and there's some serious issue
but we keep saying we want to have a
conversation we want to solve the
problem
you can't solve this problem you can't
change people's opinions you can't make
everybody all think the same
it's an isolated incident that should be
judged on an isolated incident right
right but if you're going to talk about
the pervasive problem the systemic
problem
it's a problem with crime and disregard
for members in their community well i
think you also
would have to add the underprivileged
community though
i mean they've if you live in a poorer
area aren't you more likely to commit a
crime
yeah but here's the truth poor white
people don't commit
crimes against poor black people the way
that poor black people do against
and poor white people don't commit
crimes against other poor white people
to the in the same rights
well if you're talking about drugs i
think they commit plenty of crimes
though well they do drugs but as far as
as far as robberies as far as violent
crime as far as homicide look
a black person in this country their
party is far more likely
you can steal that's true that's true
and
that being said you'd think there'd be
more because you just need to punch
through the door
punch through the wall and pull out
whatever you grab yeah no but
statistically
a black person in america is most likely
to kill be killed by a black person and
a white person
is likely to be killed by a black person
and this comes from i think right now
again like we said
black this ties back to the voting laws
black people can't get id
well hold on a second why don't it's
free well they don't know how to get
there
well they can uh we can have them do it
black people don't know how to
get online black people don't know that
bills are counterfeit this is what the
left does when you
when you have the racism the prejudice
of low
expectations black people don't know how
to use birth control
they need planned parenthood it's all
predicated on this idea
that people in those community people in
these communities meaning urban black
communities
need the white liberal savior and they
need
someone to fish for them every day that
they somehow can't be taught to fish
this is the issue that we keep running
into black people can't
go to the dmv black people can't get
online to vote
black people uh can't get into schools
unless we give them affirmative acts
black people need more money and by the
way black people can't get ahead of
white
this is according to black lives matter
if white families stay together and
there's a nuclear family so we have to
do away with that too
this is where we've this is not at all
the kind of racial justice that we were
taught that martin luther king jr was
talking about
that that we were talking about in the
80s
90s early 2 it's not even the kind of
justice that barack obama was talking
about by the way
to see how how drastically times have
changed barack obama went into
office opposing gay marriage and now
believes that men should be playing in
women's sports
donald trump is the only president who
was for gay marriage when he became
president
and for gay marriage when he left the
presidency that's how rapidly these
things
change and right now there is this
pervasive
racism from the left and i truly mean
this it really does break my heart
if a black person in the country today
someone watching if you believe for a
second
what the left has told you that you
can't get id
and that you're too dumb to use the
internet that to me that someone will
as veiled as they want it to be and they
label it under the guise of privilege
and it is so racist to me
and it robs people by the way when black
people in this country are successful
and and have worked hard it robs them of
the satisfaction
of knowing that they got ahead on their
merits and that's what bothers me about
we're not being honest about the problem
we are not being honest about the
problem if we are not acknowledging that
people like george floyd who go their
entire life
physically harming people financially
harming people
and emotionally harming people without
repercussion
it's look i'm sorry if i if i were going
if i had robbed someone
at gunpoint with a toddler there i think
they should lock me away
and if several times that day i had
stolen whether i knew or not but was
given the opportunity to make it right
that day from a local shopkeeper from
the drugstore down the street
i would expect for people to think that
i'm a piece of [ __ ]
well and the narrative was that george
floyd was turning over a new leaf
yeah that's always the narrative though
i mean that's if you watch fruitville
station or any movie that covers it i
mean that's the reality is
it's always i was trying to do good i
mean that's that's simply
not the case but same with mike brown he
was trying to do good that day he just
shoved an old guy at a liquor store
yeah it's yeah it it
it's the narrative that they usually
play out
i mean again none of this means that
there isn't that there wasn't a tragedy
that took place right
none of this means it doesn't take away
there's not a problem right right
well and but that's and we're focusing
on something that statistically is not a
problem
in comparison to what statistically is a
verifiable repeatable problem you can
see it just in this instance
with george floyd who is at great
who who presents a greater risk to
minneapolis to the streets of
minneapolis
the police force or george floyd george
floyd
here's what bothers me too is right now
i'm looking at cnn and they're airing
the commercials with the george floyd
killing still printed to the left of it
yeah with flow from progressive
yeah can someone get chaven on on her
back i know that's true i think we all
can agree
oh my god i'd like to see some urine
flow from her yeah
oh [ __ ] what what do you mean
cross the line what why are you dressed
this way i have no idea they bring
things in i do what i'm told
officer you're supposed to lean on your
neck are you going to lean on my mind
at some point it was your idea
yeah i didn't know we were actually
going to do it
we want to do it like in a video for
next time or do we want to do it live
today no no we can
so look we can show but i'm probably
going to go on your neck first and then
show you how to no don't do mine
well yeah he's the cop i'm the cop well
i know you're the cop but you don't know
how to
you don't know how to turn it in the
table all right do you want to use token
one because he's like no no no you know
what and then you know what then after
this okay since we have a break right
now i'm not going to lean on your neck
but i'll show you a basic control
position that would be in wrestling and
you'll see how uncomfortable it is
you just want to show me on the cop
there i'll show you on the camera we
have a we have a good uh
like blaze chat about that clayton b was
wondering my question is on the training
they have on this knee hold how long do
they hold it after control has been
established that's the only issue i see
once he passed out why would you stay on
the guy
so you can probably give like a yeah
that's a good well first off it's not a
position with control
that's what i'm saying so it's not a
position with control at all i don't
know why they teach it to people
right um i i think maybe they teach it
because if you have one knee on the neck
and then one knee on their torso
it controls them better uh with two
officers but even then there are still
more effective ways to do it
but believe me when i say this and
sometimes police officers get mad and
they get defensive you cannot
underestimate
the ineptitude of police department
training
when it comes to physical restraints it
is it
it's less than rudimentary and i don't
think that one man should be hung from
the gallows for
a mistake that has been made repeatedly
repeatedly and i know people love to buy
these myths look
this is something where and i think now
maybe it's more acceptable because we
understand that the military for example
is now a petri dish for social justice
warrior ideology but people used to
think that if i said hey
you know what there are some myths that
people attribute to special forces that
aren't true people are like oh
no they can kill you with their bran no
look we would have navy seals we would
have
marines we would have special forces we
would have army rangers we would have
taken from any branch
coming to the the school which was an
mma school and i just did brazilian jiu
jitsu and some basic boxing
they would get rolled up by blue belts
why because they're they're not trained
fighters
they're trained with firearms they're
supposed to be trained in de-escalation
they're trained where if they have five
people they can use a taser but that
being said
because they get people through this
training pretty quickly
they have to go to the tools on their
belt which are weapons
and that by itself escalates the
situation
most police officers out there today i
would say the vast majority
are not physically capable of
restraining someone to the degree
of a ninth grade high school wrestler
yeah that's probably pretty accurate
yeah i mean just a little bit and small
female officers are capable of
restraining george floyd
never yeah never if if george floyd if
it was a small female officer who
responded to george floyd
she probably wouldn't be able to cuff
him her only option is to taser shoot
yeah well and i think token owen you
probably what do you weigh
uh say it on air 185
a very a very good comparison would be
having him kneel on your neck
instead of me who i'm i'm this i'm
bigger than george floyd
yeah right so it would be like having
token one kneel on your neck
all right give me the money that's the
weight and he looks better in this
that's really
okay all right give toca now on the
mustache i would look like the female
cop
so if you want to demonstrate that like
the female cop who shows up in the
sitcom with the belt too high like all
right what's going on here hey
hey it's melissa mccarthy yes melissa
mccarthy
yeah one other one might be this cops
completely inept why would you hire her
and all of this too is speaking of al
sharpton oh my god they're doing the
chain link thing please
someone turn this up for us to trust
this it's a ridiculous
tie he's got just really lost coming out
i know this kind of guy should put some
weight back on yeah he is it's like ow
ow ow there's a level between you know
you and little nicky you you being
pretty you know portly and tom hanks
philadelphia
what's the difference emaciated and
obese there is a there is a line in
between
now it looks like the little bug that
one could chew you just need a curvy l
sharp
al sharpton is one of my least favorite
people on the planet i think it's uh
anybody who's you or
jewish again yeah no because he called
them roaches that's true well farrakhan
again huckster they don't care about uh
the anti-semitic attacks coming from
uh people like fair economy oh of course
i want to claim that it's from
the people in the republican party who
you know support a strong alliance with
israel
yeah just like with asians they don't
they don't want to acknowledge the fact
that asians have been getting
screwed in uh admittance in colleges
like we've been talking about just at
stanford and brown alone we've done
multiple stories on this
they don't want to talk about that they
want you to think that now it's
uh the people who believe in a
meritocracy who uh have been committing
hate crimes against asians
this is the divide and conquer and i
just i will say this like i i try and be
a
happy warrior as much as i can but we
don't have much longer
going going on with this right now we
don't have much longer going on
with it's not just racial division
because
i i i will allow for the fact that
sometimes solutions will be
uncomfortable for
people of any race gender creeds
sometimes everyone has to look at
themselves and there's going to be
division
on solutions to the problem i understand
that the issue is that we're starting
out dishonestly
and that is happening all the time right
now that's why i'm so concerned look do
i care that i've been banned
that i've been suspended from twitter
not so much what worries me is that i
was suspended for simply pointing out
that twitter doesn't list reasons for
suspension
does it worry do i lose any money by the
fact that our one-year anniversary
written day 15 days to flatten the curve
was removed from youtube nope i don't
believe it was monetized anyway so it
doesn't change my pocketbook one time
but it scares me it scares me that
youtube says
hey this show using cdc guidelines using
the world health organization
using medical you everything was coming
from pup you can go to littlefinder.com
and see the sources listed for that show
them saying
but we don't want this here because the
solution needs to
start from whatever dr fauci says
lockdowns
that's what worries me we don't have
much we don't have that long going down
this trail
of starting off from a dishonest premise
are they have they gone back now and
they're called witnesses they're calling
witnesses okay who is this witness
right here and then you can lean on me
afterwards there can you tell the jurors
what your occupation is
i am a minneapolis 911 dispatcher
and so who was your employer city of
minneapolis
and how long have you been doing that
almost seven years
can you tell the jurors you know what
kind of training goes into being a
dispatcher
um we hang up on anyone named aaron
through
close to two years of training starting
with call taking
where citizens are calling 9-1-1 with
their emergencies
also speaking to non-emergencies and how
we can direct those
we then work with police and fire on
sending them their calls
and prioritizing them also you put me on
hold for nine minutes playing earth wind
and fire
last time i called it that was rude i
said i was being stabbed
in my house please hold
help but dance oh this is gonna hurt the
edible also found some footage of george
floyd from may 2019
in a very similar um police stop that uh
they're saying might be used by the
defense oh yeah do we have it yeah
all right let me what this is this is
footage of george floyd
from may 2019 i'm seeing this for the
first time because who was the other guy
who we found that
i found that other pullover that no one
had seen um ray shard brooks remember
ray shard brooks or the other pullover
where he was by the train tracks
yeah and i don't think anyone else still
showed that
uh but this is now um george floyd
and we've confirmed that that is him for
sure george floyd 2019
uh washington for the first time with
you
i'm not going to shoot you put your
hands on the dash
put your hands on the dash the last time
i'm going to tell you that it's simple
he keeps moving his hands around
he won't listen
hands are not on top of his head
okay relax then
hmm so it's kind of his go-to is don't
shoot me don't shoot me and okay okay
okay but not brad with the ass behavior
and yeah now look people go drunk oh he
was just putting a pill in his mouth
sure he could have been reaching for a
gun he was obviously trying to put a
pill in his mouth so there wasn't the
evidence that's most likely what was
happening
yeah um but if someone says put your
hand put your hands in the dash
and you don't they can't see where your
hands are
yeah if you're in a high crime
neighborhood and your police officer
that works there and knows that it's
and it's a guy clearly with a history if
they run his plates with no problem
using firearms against his fellow
citizens yeah he has
how old is was george floyd 46
i don't know uh i know he was in his 40s
okay
yeah when he died he was 46 so that was
and that was 2019 so probably 14 44.
uh no one he died he was 46. he said 45
but that pull over
i'm saying he would have been 40. oh i
got you in another room you'll have your
fire dispatchers to give them who am i
correcting
you can work around that and be on the
radio and listen to the firefighters
across the room you will have our
channel 7 that is
closely located to our dispatch group
which is approximately four people so
this is
i will say this the lawyer here on the
left he has a mouth
like when you're looking up at a
hammerhead shark
i mean there's a chance though that he
was tuned up by cops a few times
which could lead him to having this
reaction yeah
sure sure again that's not saying the
cops responsible
someone's hearty oh i'm sure he can be
but he could help explain his behavior
yes
but more likely he's a criminal who
doesn't want to go to jail well i think
that's any
drug addict really i mean and are they
criminals are they sick
i mean yeah i mean usually hand in hand
well hold on let's also be right there
there's a difference between being a
drug addict and being a serial violent
offender which george floyd yes there is
absolutely i agree we are not doing the
same which hey let me ask you this one
quick question
i wasn't trying to say no no i know you
weren't i know you weren't and i think
it's good that you're here asking these
questions because i think this is listen
this is an emotionally charged issue
and people need to understand he's like
jesse
what are ventura suggesting jesse i
don't know was george w
bush outside tower 7 with an acme
plunger before it went down
i'm just asking the facts i saw dan
quayle put dynamite into tower one
you would know that too if you weren't
so busy asking about which
kardashian's ass is most fat cause
you're not asking about the facts
it's kim
[Laughter]
do you think bob kardashian's just
looking up from hell like they're all
getting banged
by athletes those are my girls
here's my question too this is something
i was just wondering the other day
because and i and i agree that the war
on drugs is
largely a failure but what i have always
said is if you just legalize all drugs
which sometimes the solution they go you
really think that the drug cartels are
going to straighten up and fly white
fly right like oh i'm going to start
doing turbo taxes like what do you think
is going to happen
but what's so funny to me is like well
the war on drugs you see many people on
the left say that we need to legalize
all drugs was it portland who just did
it portland or seattle
or oregon there was some place that just
legalized all drugs
washington uh denver i think right no it
wasn't colorado no
somewhere in the uh i believe it was a
city in i believe it was a city in
washington
or decriminalized maybe not legalized
yeah but it was everything was
decriminalized
including like black tar heroin yes
which i'm not gonna lie i don't really
know the difference between stan
i don't know the difference between
black tar heroine and heroin regular
they're both but
that day's like well actually i've only
done one yeah
it's pretty but here's my question
people who are against the drug war they
go it's failed because look you just put
money in the hands of drug cartels
then they also want to ban
semi-automatic firearms
do you have any idea how much money
there will be to be made
in in gun running looks like it was the
entire state of oregon too by the way oh
wow okay great oh shocking
i was right well of course they're just
going to go to another illegal activity
well
i know but it's just ironic to me where
people go well we need to we need to
legalize all drugs because the drug war
and you're putting the money in the
house look there are three ways that
drug cartels drug run
that these illegal criminal uh
operations where they make money okay
drugs guns prostitution
human trafficking really yeah human
trafficking so if you legalize all drugs
they're just going to traffic more
people
and then if you make guns illegal well
you've actually just added a profit
margin
well you've also now you have free range
to take the drugs that break those
prostitutes
and yeah i shouldn't be grinning but you
know no i know what you're saying
it's a valid point left you shouldn't
have a smile on your face dave
serious that's because you spent a lot
of the time in the bathroom yeah
yes hey dave so by the way i do have a
question for you chuck berry room
i think you have a good perspective on
this but knowing what you know
now about dope no about this trial
right because i think a lot of people
they just saw the hype for this right
they just saw like the media
hype and hysteria over what was going on
but knowing what you know now having
seen the entire video having some
context to it do you think it's now
okay to go down and burn the walgreens
down or maybe that was an overreach oh i
didn't think that was okay i know you
were i'm being sarcastic about that
but like this was the basis for the
riots
during by the way something that we were
all supposed to be so afraid of
that we couldn't go outside covet we had
a spike right after the riots but
obviously it wasn't because of covet
and we had property damage around the
country people's lives ruined people's
lives destroyed
killed all because of this this is what
started it
this was a breath of fresh air to people
that were angry and were locked up i
mean this is all a result of one thing
leading to another i mean
covert was something that was used in my
personal opinion
simply to get trump out of office and
demonize him which then led to this
which further demonized him saying it
was his america
and i wasn't even this diehard fan of
trump but if anybody fails to see that
this is all a result of of cause and
effect yeah
i mean that's the reality is we wanted
to play this game of white supremacy
that
and i'm not saying that that doesn't
exist to some degree
in the world or hasn't ever no but that
doesn't but
the the idea that everything should be
riding on this
and the fact that our country and our
future is riding on this and more
people's businesses
that's the part that i don't understand
either the white rioters going into
black neighborhoods and burning down
their community
it makes no sense to me
they don't they they fight fascism
fascism yes yeah yeah they
they fight old women until their big
sons walk out their molotov cocktailing
their truth yeah that's true and i also
like the word my truth because it means
it's a lie
such a cute way of putting that yeah but
i i do think it's
it's disturbing what's ended up
happening and you've watched how
because you needed an excuse if you lock
people up take away their jobs
i mean look at george floyd even for
example he had he had no money he had a
counterfeit bill whether he knew it or
not
which he got because of a collapsed
economy and losing his job
the guy was probably pissed off went to
get a pack of cigarettes
i wasn't going to give them back that's
a job well i said they said that's what
they said
but so going off every bit of evidence
we saw he had just lost a job
so he lost the job because if he was a
nightclub balancer he did
i mean no doubt i thought that he hadn't
worked at that club in a while but well
at least that's the excuse was given
that he lost it he did lose his
job so maybe he didn't want to give the
cigarettes back he was like well [ __ ]
you i have nothing i'm pissed off
yeah yeah you know i'm not saying that
gives an excuse but but when you're when
you've been locked
up and detained and you've been in
prison then you're out and you've been
locked up and detained again by the
government for reasons you don't
understand
and you're a drug addict it's a powder
keg and approved it because the whole
country burned
right yeah so yeah this sucks i mean
this is good
but i think it's important to note that
everyone was locked up i agree
everyone and only one half burned the
country
that's right we need to be clear about
that that's where people say well it's
not it's left and right no no
you have one example long after the
country burned the tune of two billion
dollars with
200 people out of several hundred
thousand at the capitol um
but one side of this country burned it
down and
one party encouraged it mala harris vice
president
president saying uh well they shouldn't
stop
get used to it this is a new normal and
they shouldn't stop rioting
i don't know how donald trump is guilty
of inciting violence and kamala harris
isn't
i don't know how all the staffers who
smoked weed have been fired and kamala
harris is still vp
so i'm still figuring out some of this
not fair
well it's great though because we have
higher gas prices they now want to
charge you for mileage that you're
driving
they're firing people for weeds so you
guys voted in the right team
yeah good job enjoy being poor again
how's that vote working out for you and
enjoy the international community going
oh
my biden's in the okay we can do
whatever we want yeah we're gonna do
whatever we want
you know like they are now where they're
like we're not even gonna talk to them
yeah i don't know i don't know but i
haven't made up my mind yet yeah due to
roman candle that one
no it's infuriating because we have all
these cameras and eyes on things in the
public and it hasn't done us a service
no it hasn't done us a service because
people like al sharpton
rushed to the scene to say it was
systemic well here's the thing it used
to be al sharpton he was a joke but
guess what
he's no different from elizabeth warren
joe biden kamala harris right now
al sharpton is less radical than
everyone in the dnc
think about that for a second right now
people in office right now
are tarring and feathering everybody
everybody who they
who are police officers they're saying
defund the police they're saying we have
systemic discrimination
we know statistically verifiably it's
not true
the issue here is just like with coven
starting off
with a lie yeah it started off with 2.2
2.4 million dead the imperial college
study one and silencing anyone who said
and they're still silencing
because we're nowhere near that number
by the way and youtube removed our
entire
episode on that so it started with a lie
we're gonna have 2.4 million unless we
do 15 days to flatten the girl
yeah well that was a lie and now the lie
we need to defund the police because
they're shooting black men in record
numbers
that's a lie that is a lie what is not a
lie
is that george floyd the way he lived
his
life does not mean he deserve to die is
far more indicative of the statistical
problem
that the black community has to deal
with on a daily basis
37 times the violent crime rate
that doesn't even include counterfeit
bill and having no empathy for the guy
who needs to feed his kids
at the was it cup cup food supply that's
right
well that cnn used to say jake tapper
said the big lie was when donald trump
said the election was stolen and that is
what is responsible for the january six
riots on the capitol right the
insurrection
the big lie right this is harkening back
to to germany in a very bad period of
time he pulled that comment out
the big lie has been telling this
country for the last year that if you're
black the police are going to shoot you
randomly
and that led to violence that led to
people's lives being lost why is there
no accountability for them
why is there no accountability for those
guys who are saying hey if you go and
lie in public donald trump and you tell
people this election was stolen
and they go and take over the capital
it's your fault jake tapper
you said that this country was
systemically racist people went out they
rioted people's lives were lost is that
not your fault also why the [ __ ] does
vermont not have a 15
minimum wage bernie
that's true come on i was just thinking
about this the other day i'm sorry but i
was sitting there like what is it can
someone look it up i think in vermont
it's like 11 50.
i remember i read it and i thought that
must be a misprint cheaper housings they
don't have to pay as much
you got to work 10 hours to go see fish
[Laughter]
no you are right though i mean it's like
oh
1500 you first the insurrection the
so stupid it's not i mean the guy in the
wooly yeah
the woolly mammoth the insert was it
10.78 are we sure
1078 and then it moved to 11.75 11.75
ah commonly referred to as bernie's tip
on a 400
tab the soup was cold
there was glass in my soup sir i saw you
take the broken glass
out of your suit pocket and sprinkle it
in there eyeballed
why didn't you eat some of it before
putting in the glass i don't know i
don't know anymore
i wasn't committed to the role at this
point it's really more for the thrill
i want you to have an equal amount of
glass in your soup as i have in my soup
equal take some glass for me
by the way did you know that if i throw
a baseball uh uh out the window the
glass will go out the window if you
throw it in that's how they catch
criminals have you been reading more
sherlock holmes pictures
i use it as a power cleanse from marx
and lennon marty
we gotta go back to 1985.
oh my gosh i am just just honestly that
the fact that this is that that
right now people are tuning in you know
what this is the the inverse of what
happened with clarence thomas and that's
what turned andrew breitbart into a
conservative
there are people who tune in thinking
this guy's a a monster and really what
equated to i think some people refer to
it as a modern day lynching and you
should have seen joe biden when he was
sitting there talking
and then people realized this is
character assassin that was sort of the
first time it happened
they tried to claim that he was a
regular at a porno shop which didn't
actually it couldn't have even been but
we shouldn't it shouldn't even matter
the fact that clarence thomas made a
joke
about a pubic hair on a diet coke can
shouldn't matter if he had gone to a to
a seedy
uh video rental store right but this is
what happened back then we're
gonna make sure we have a trial and it's
gonna be racially based that's what
happened on the flip side
same thing with oj this is it's just not
true and it also isn't something that
most
black americans feel they may feel that
sometimes they're there's racial
profiling
because of this almost race war that the
media is trying to incite at this point
but most black americans statistically
we can bring that up
but want at least as much of a police
presence as there is now or more they
don't want to defund the police
they don't different different from the
van jones the talking heads on cnn
they don't want that they don't want bad
police in the street
and neither do i neither does anybody
well and i
i was very just anti-cop in general at
one point in my life and i'm not
obviously anymore but
i worked at a luggage store in downtown
detroit which we had pretty much an
all-black clientele and i do remember
having conversations with
older black people where they were just
like oh yeah well you don't want them
now but if you're in trouble all of a
sudden you're going to want them and i
mean they felt the same way in their
community it's the same as
there's an old woman used to wash dishes
at uh this this
uh war memorial is what it was called
that i worked at and you drive her home
and you get to her street and her street
was burnt out but her house was
immaculate
yeah you get that was she like polish
something you have some of these no she
was a black woman and she would get out
every night and she would pick up the
trash that was left on her lawn just
while she was at work she couldn't
afford to get out of that neighborhood
right yeah there are people that do
definitely care about that and do want
more of a police you find that in
detroit and a lot of times
you'll find like some old polish guys
who can't afford to get out on
retirement oh in hamtramck for sure yeah
well even in detroit downtown yeah you
do yeah yeah but yeah you will you will
gran torino right but they replaced
black people with mung and we were all
supposed to believe there wasn't any in
detroit
um no but uh you see this in detroit too
where you will find
burn down building crack house or meth
den i don't really yeah or just
uh water you know nothing and then you
will see
a yard that is immaculate immaculate it
looks like you know something out of a
world war
ii movie we're like and once we came
home the victors look at the allies
they go in the white picket fence but
you will see it next to what looks like
a war zone
and that's just because and it's just a
perfect example of
oh even in the worst scenario
you can respect your stuff yeah well
they have the auto guns from congo set
up around so it's true that's true makes
that much easier
to deal with a lot of booby traps
back there which is also a trip on eight
miles and white gorillas with
lasers yes everybody deserves a hot meal
yes
well i'm conflating that part of it is
pride of ownership like i said she was a
dishwasher
there's something about when you work
for something and it's not handed to you
and i think that goes for
it goes for anything free comedy club
tickets a car that might be given to you
anything if you don't have to work for
something you just
for some reason a lot of human nature is
just to not take care of it
when you've worked hard through your
entire life to afford this house
wherever it's at
if it's something you love you see
people take care of that because they
put value in their work
if you buy a house in detroit right now
even look people it's a punch line but
you worked hard for the six dollars to
procure it that's true exactly
you waited in line at an auction of two
people that had four dollars
you gave up a latte you traded
you traded that ponderosa coupon
you traded up sir ponderosa's still
around i don't think it's the owner's
name
joe ponderosa all right sorry let's go i
think we're missing the test i apologize
i just this is
a dispatch lady i mean not that she's
not important but what is she going to
say yes i dispatched
there now they're they're saying uh the
guy's line of questioning seems
completely aimless so far just asking
about precinct names and dispatch codes
so
that's what i i don't feel like anything
she has a lanyard you
yeah sorry look i don't know i don't i
thought and she has a stick behind her
there
why does she have a stick like a pointer
stick a metal it's six feet distant
stick
is that what it is would you be shocked
it sounds like now they're getting they
are getting to the floor dispatch now
all right let's go you want to
see track
[Laughter]
shift or they cut to either side and a
guy's making sandwiches
multiple screens yes
everything looks different um it would
take a lot of explaining
but yes we see all isn't that why you're
a witness
[Music]
well if we have to go over this it's
going to be a long day and
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh you want me to explain
well how is he gonna uh tiles are boring
how's it gonna be
a racist stuff in its client's ear
[Laughter]
you're right he doesn't take into
account rebound oh
this isn't ghost colored colored oh geez
son
i told you it doesn't look like jesus
christ
you just have a bunch of just a bunch of
br black hebrew israelites right now
walk with uh
burlap sex all these letters to jesus
christ
[Laughter]
those who are into theology right or
greg kinnear movies
that too what was that letters to santa
yeah yeah
151 is received they're drinking
for 151 to be put up on the screen so we
can all see it
and we're going to light it and we're
all going to do a shot
we all need it it's the first page of
this document
and i'll represent you that we have not
included the entire document
right this is just a question thank
goodness for that that's correct correct
so what i'm going to ask you to do here
with the first line
is tell us you know run us through that
first line and tell us the information
on that very top line the first line is
from the call taker
it is a query of the plate that's in the
call and then the first line is uh
mike lindell showing where the votes
went to texas
she just called that lawyer query
[Laughter]
you should know your query you should
know query
are you talking about my turtle mask
320 suv license plate my wife called it
this morning
okay so what i'm going to do is math
query blown up a little bit so it's
easier for everybody to read along with
you
and that's a readalong at least the
first
couple lines just so that it's
bigger for us all to see
so the first column on the left
self-explanatory that's the date correct
do you like when it gets bigger
also probably self-explanatory um
what does user mean user would be
how you identify different persons
involved
this person you can tell is a call taker
it's the first two
um letters there and then it has their
id number
we all have our own id numbers and so
what's your id number
mine is one two three zero now and your
phone number yes
first seven digits hobbies
white or red yeah you like a stick
into vegetarian what do you like how do
you know
curry are you wearing panties oh geez
i think that's inappropriate this is uh
common legal i don't want to bother you
it's really pro these are this is legal
jurgen you need not bother yourself with
i want to get all the facts don't worry
about
[Laughter]
just smell her hair and just be a biden
okay i've got a bloodhound
nose sandly uh candley remove your
lanyard i'm going to dust for prince
they say she's a little dim but them
titties ain't nothing
stop it tell me my favorite bits and
then just on 38th street it's providing
the information of where
we try to be as clear as possible and
paint a picture so many viewers
it's true though degenerates shut up
yes and as part of this process
does that information also go can we
have someone bring up a
picture of a hammerhead shark from
underneath because
it's his mouth a little bit yeah it
really is just
he's very muppety correct yes
where's like beaker
yes and then there's an address what a
boring trial
i know right laws totally not like on tv
yeah it's totally not someone get nancy
grace to scream about a missing child
yeah that's what we need sometimes i do
this for you
by the way the uh the third line there
the third line is actually important it
says suspected of being under the
influence i think or appears this person
is under the influence
and that was shared with all the
officers before they got there so they
knew that going in
is your response here of correct
and do you spell that with three or four
m how do you do that
could you show us how you did it do you
mind if i loosen my tie it's getting
hot in here feel free to loosen yours
oh you're not wearing one we'll feel
free to loosen whatever it is that you
you wear yeah
whatever there's a chemistry going on
[Music]
you know there's a motel 6 not far from
here and i only need
15 minutes of recess six minutes with
you uh well you know what uh
uh attorney i don't think i'm
comfortable well i'll tell you what i'll
just leave the key here and i'll leave
the light on for you here you go
oh i seem to have left my motel room
[Laughter]
just under the glass you just see yeah
sure what is that it's not a marriott
cake nothing
mariachi who am i a rockefeller it's
motel 6.
we could both look out the window while
it happens at the protesters
i originally dispatched this to three
feet third floor room so we can feel
better than that yeah
and look down at the pleats i want to
make sure i have this right so this is
matthew frank this is the
the prosecutor right now and then his
lanyard is for real
sorry
by the way hammerhead sharks are really
unpredictable sometimes they're fine you
can swim touch them and then sometimes
they just thrash it
yes oh i think we should make them all
extinct that's right
and prior to uh coming to court
did you have an opportunity to listen to
a copy of that call
did you have an opportunity to get lunch
or should we
he's mirroring his phone with the
exhibits and they just see him dialing
panera yeah
pardon me i'm placing my order uh now
for example d
double d wow you and this page have a
lot in common
is this dave's terrible pickup lines yes
completely what does the tag on your
lanyard say
made in no it says george floyd trial oh
no i thought it said made in heaven
it has been referred to as jesus christ
is a black male 6
foot or taller why'd you stop
why would you stop i apologize you're
under the call was made using vonage
[Laughter]
they were already kind of defunded
everything's cricket wireless
inside the travis barker those
commercials really uh
got me now what do you do he did amped
mobile there's like boost mobile i don't
know
i think he had had technical
difficulties there boy they're having
more technical difficulties in this show
on the outside crazy yeah
can we play it okay can we get that clip
i'm just on i'm on national television
guys
somebody please i my shark mouth is
going to be noticed anytime
i don't like eyes on me i can only
obfuscate it if i keep moving yeah
i'm sorry your honor the part where she
said it looks like he's under the
influence of a controlled substance has
been deleted
do you know a lot about somebody who's
under the influence of a controlled
substance ma'am
yes yes i do experiments later loving
you
the love drug i wear magnums [ __ ]
[Laughter]
sometimes you just gotta go fishing with
dynamite
nuclear option oh you got to do what
you're going to do
is he walking off again it's like joe
biden
putting a mask on he's just all
willy-nilly about it
in the case he spoke to the
people in the courtroom beforehand
saying that why does john king look like
he just woke up from a nap now
he probably did see the judge he looks
like he looks like he just loves
his face stuff that anderson coopers i
love how he's giving us the play-by-play
of what's happening in the courtroom and
now the judge
all right he's got his hand on his mouth
right now there is a technical issue we
are getting more information i know hold
stay with us
is that frozen the feeder is that judge
just really still he's very still he's
very still
the blue thing to avoid predators
[Laughter]
process he saw the hammerhead shark
mouth and went
he's coming closer what what are you
doing you'll think i'm a cnn
i'm just floating along if you notice
that blue thing on his desk also sticks
to a shower wall
why is she where is she where is she
she's in denver or something
says no i don't know what she's in front
of a ski lodge yeah
i'm here at the ski and cafe ski and ski
out cafe
uh and i know about as much as you mr
king i'll be honest i heard about this
trial and i want to be what people ski
if i get my drift
the first thing that records is actually
not your voice
correct all right so we'll try to
exhibit 10 again what's going on with
the mug there i thought i just broke
don't raise this dave
what
yes you can't be racist and like tits
3 30 is the only available out of your
sector
to cup food from chicago 37 59 chicago
on 38th they are reporting that there's
a person who used the colors that fill
in the business
why does their 911 logo
their 911 on their shirt look like a six
flags logo
that's actually a uh gibbons family
reunion jacket
looks
if i knew i was end up on trial i would
have been a little more peppy that day
right the officers on the street correct
correct all right
back back up and run through this a
little bit could you
back that up and run it through it oh no
and you initially called us out to 3 30
correct correct
do you recall who was working in 3 30
that day
i don't specifically know well
because i actually have an answer it
seems that you were
working it yes
after that it wasn't just at 3 30. looks
like this is 24
7. that's impressive and what does that
how do you do it
they acknowledge that they've been given
a call and subsequent to that there was
a call
from 320 correct yes
you heard the tape what was the
substance of that call
again you heard the tales what the hell
so
basically do i look handsome to you i
went to great clips
i don't feel it was great it was good i
mean i'm not upset about my hair but
it's not the best it's ever looked
yeah usually i'm a super cuts guy yeah
they were back
booked up pending a priority i called
they said i got a trial to do
nothing uh sometimes i will clear a
squad i bet you clear squad
advise present there's a multitude of
different reasons
and i instead just put it back later to
finish whatever
here's the problem this is dave as a
juror as well making these jokes in his
head
yeah it's a good thing i'm not yeah i'm
not a jeweler
i'd be like that hammerhead that
hammerhead's trying to bang that witness
yeah
and then he's going to eat the turtle
that's
that's in my dissenting opinion it's a
hung jury it's like
i did not think the hammerhead did a
very good job
yeah this guy doesn't take any of this
seriously and he keeps ordering more
expensive lunches
come on guys we can get red lobster in
here at some point
you know what i'm talking about huh
right witness
say do you like red lobster
but did you eventually yes all right
so if we can go back to 151 please
of course i love red light it's my
favorite
but it's not my birthday why would you
bring me there
i celebrate their entire menu yes
i love lobster season shrimp season i
celebrate their entire seasonal
catalogue
i don't even know how it makes sense
that there's a season for an animal
[Laughter]
this is why trials take forever where is
he going with any of this nowhere how
does this matter
can you just be like yeah is this you is
this what you said here's the tape all
right that's the evidence next
i think it's just because lawyers get
paid by the hour i think that's
true and he's on tv i'm not kidding this
trial is on tv
everywhere right now and they know that
yeah it's either this or
william shatner reading the name of your
firm yeah
it says uh i mean i i hopefully they're
building the case
well this is the the state prosecutors
though right so these are the people
i know but i'm hoping that they're going
you know they're going to build it to
something interesting
nobody i mean were you the dispatch yes
did you send them people yes
i could have covered this for 30 seconds
did the plate say it was george floyd
yeah yeah you thought did they say they
thought it was on drugs yeah thank you
okay next next john
what's your netflix
[Laughter]
what's your biological what's your
circadian rhythm like
what's your what's the policy on
personal 9-1-1 calls
is this a banana in my pocket my pants
are about to peel
one of those call logs is just him the
transcript
what are you wearing so are you
reporting a crime
not yet no but there's gonna be
because if that ass don't get tapped it
should be illegal
[Laughter]
at the very least a gross injustice of
the system
systematic issues oh man
if i don't get next to that thing there
is no justice
and we'll make fun of the men too just
i'm going to throw on a lobster bed but
the thing i'm going to eat won't be
dinner
oh you know what i'm saying no what are
you talking about it means you
gonna oh well that i should never have
asked
let's give him a ding for that i'm just
good at it it's going to be a mess
that's my point
i think we're going to need to go live
to tape with dave by the way
my sister all his shots are pre-taped
i mean i'm in a different outfit every
time you cut to me
great thoughts david oh good very good
didn't he die three years ago still
using him we get his reactions
those are really good just tape 12
things of me and have me killed
i'm trying to see what we've got oh
we've got the prosecutors i guess
theoretically when you signed your
contract it's in perpetuity
it is you could do really whatever i
mean every once in a while what do you
think dave
and you know you pretty much just need
me to make an
incest joke and a 911 joke and you can
just put it on a loop
[Laughter]
how long are they going to do this oh
wait we're going through line by live
well what does this mean well what does
this mean what does this mean what does
this mean
could somebody somebody turn up the air
conditioning in here
i'm waiting for it to get to 57 hold
please move to the next page
what a boring connection
i have watched law and order and never
seen anything like this is nothing like
the movies
i hope he's found guilty just because i
have to sit through this
oh now they're doing a juxtaposition
there's more oh okay let's see what is
this
see that yes can you describe what's
uh listed there what what that line is
about
i believe i heard ems code 2 for a mouth
injury
requested by the squad and so that's 320
calling in
for that correct correct and so
code 2 you told us earlier means what
non-emergent
and then describe for is then what's
depicted in the next line at 20
21 35. squad 330 requested ems code
three
so this is uh upgrade 330
upgrading the call to code 3. that's it
yes
yes and um so look though you've got a
pretty smiley mouth really just to be
clear when we talk about ems
we might think of that as an ambulance
right correct all right
and then the next line at 22 7. you
should smile more
it's a good deal your smile makes me
smile it was
information for the paramedics that
police had the male restraints speaking
my pants have just been upgraded to an
em3
also i have a mouth entry i need you to
check out
do my tonsils look smaller now
are you trained in mouth-to-mouth
resuscitation
um no i'm not i don't need to involve
the paramedics
i gotta hit an atm and i ain't talking
about the bank
you know what i'm saying you but i'm
flexible i can do the back of the car or
the ground
i might look old but i am stunningly
stunningly flexible
i'm like a little asian girl gymnast but
i'm an old white man
so we're adding additional agency to
that
now explain why like is ems different
than fire yes
household one's a fire
and this is them riding in here
adding the additional fire fire is
clearly firefighters but they are
medically trained they can be
speaking of which i went shopping at
men's warehouse would you say this
outfit is quote unquote fire
i was told i was gonna like the way i
look
[Laughter]
do you like the way i look
sure it's a little expensive but i got
that kind of coin it really is it's the
only that matters you're the expert with
412 ems is now located at parking you
believe i got two
suits for a hundred dollars
[Laughter]
how about these shirts they threw in for
free yeah they're pretty nice i got some
cufflinks
but the good thing is with the shirts
they gave me i don't need them
they have buttons there's really no need
for the cufflinks whatsoever
i got stopped going through the metal
detector it took us eight tries
[Laughter]
it's because i had them in my pocket
[Laughter]
i forgot completely i'm like my keys are
in the dish it is an
automatic thing once you are adding the
agencies
so fire would not be able to see that
unless they had their own call
and so the line above that
is the multi-agency fire is adding fire
all right i just see this
getting increasingly immature with dave
and i so yeah i really know where to go
there he is he's on the hunt so you're
saying they didn't send a fire truck to
kill a guy
yes yes oh would did they think they
were more racist than the cops is that
why they sent them
yes sir was it a smoke signal was a
lizard i don't know about that but i
know that you stopped
this heart i can't breathe excuse me is
your last name
fentanyl because i can't breathe
too soon yeah thank you
hey hey hey hey i know what you're
thinking you usually don't hang out with
strangers but
i'm not that kind of guy
could you please stop flirting with a
witness shut up bane
i'll do what i want can you please stop
playing
take my breath away just the wrong theme
song
just cuz he's a he's something from say
anything
[Laughter]
he doesn't really know what to go it's
just playing top 40 hip-hop yeah yeah
you like this whatever channels
i heard that you do
that's a commercial for debt cleansing
comedy helps us express our emotions
sorry all right is there anything that i
should wrap up here with the fact
well and you let us know um well you
know what we'll take your chat here
we'll go to mug club for people who are
still here
um little squad.com mug club and we'll
just take your chats but uh you let us
know too in the comments section the
best thing you can do obviously is
comment let us know if you want us to be
covering this
trial uh or specifically you want us
just covering moments that we think will
be
if anything not horribly uninteresting
like this
uh because i know it's a historical
moment but i think people look back and
they remember the highlights
of like oh jay they're like the glove
and they don't remember
johnny cochran listing his grocery list
for now yes
that's true this isn't court tv stephen
right can't build a network on 24-hour
coverage they're really not gonna
highlight
these highlights that he's using right
now that is for sure
that is the worst there's no reason to
have this
uh i'm trying to see if there's anything
here that we also need to fact check now
it seems like we pretty much got
uh all this right just to be clear uh
hennepin county the
the dr andrew bakers who were talking
about this earlier because the
prosecution said they were going to
bring out the lady who trained
thompson baker dr thompson um he's the
one who conducted the only autopsy
just be clear he's the only one who
actually conducted an autopsy and in
that autopsy some other information i
didn't give you earlier there were blood
uh gas tests showed an exceptionally
high blood level of co2 drugs that
suppress breathing and cause co2 to
accumulate in the blood there were not
only no asphyxiation there were no
bruises to the neck
at all which is surprising to me no
hemorrhaging no evidence of restricted
airflow
no mechanical asphyxia femoral blood
draw showed high levels of fentanyl
methamphetamine the state
purposely contracted private examiners
to contradict the findings by the way
he's the only one who actually conducted
the official autopsy
um and yeah and it showed in a lot what
we already know an enlarged heart with
something called
extra-adrenal perigla ganglioma
that's a tumor that secretes adrenal
genome yeah which sounds like a bad
combo when mixed with terrible
methane uh yeah that's no good i think
you have a heart attack
yeah so uh this is uh this is you know
this is sad and you know what the truth
is uh they're banking on you not
watching the boring stuff and
this is this is the issue because i also
understand it is boring it is yeah this
is terrible it's boring
and that guy is probably gonna go home
with her to the red lobster yeah
and they'll have a wonderful time but
i'm guilty of being a player
those biscuits literally those biscuits
anything else
no don't hate the player endless bus
boys at red lobster because they
they're dilly deadly um i think the
problem with this is uh
um the media is going to pull extreme
clips just like before
there isn't going to be illumination for
most people now a lot of people tune in
watch the opening statements i think
that's a good thing
because many people had no idea if you
watched cnn you wouldn't know about the
drugs in the system
or the level to which uh he was
intoxicated
you wouldn't know about the actual
autopsy
and the report you wouldn't know about
the toxicology report
this was never told on mainstream media
so that
might slip through and i'm really
grateful that we have this platform so
we're able to punch through when youtube
doesn't decide to remove it or twitter
ban me
but keep in mind that this is going to
be going on for a very very long time
and just like many of you remember
certain moments from the oj trial
or many of you remember certain i'm
trying to think well really the oj trial
is the big one that i can think of
oh yeah that would be one you have
certain moments that you you've
forgotten a lot of what happened because
these things went on for weeks
and that's because the media hand-picked
what they wanted you to see and
considering what we know right now
about the media and their lackeys in
washington dc right now they're going to
hand-pick the most damning clips and so
i just expect it to be a repeat of the
same they'll show the clip of him on the
ground
they won't show the 10-minute clip
leading up where he's saying that he
can't breathe
they're going to show you uh probably
some clips that show
floyd being a great family man and a
member of the community they're not
going to show you that he committed a
crime against a member of the community
that day they're not going to show you
his violent rap sheet they're not going
to show you
the multiple times that he resisted
arrest so what i am still worried about
is
this is going to be going on and people
will think well at least everything's
out in the open now and
justice was served when the fact is most
people aren't in the know
most people aren't paying attention and
the media is going to use this as an
opportunity to lead you by the nose so
if you don't watch it with us uh you
need to be watching at the very least
like i've always said
find some conservative websites right
leading websites and find some
left-leaning websites and match them up
you should you should always go
one-to-one if you go to fox news and go
to cnn
if you go to whatever it is so go to our
website then go to
whatever lgbtq blog spot that says we're
hitler
my point is just line them up left and
right left and right so that at least
you know what both sides are saying
on this story because you can't expect
anyone to be honest with you and
frankly we don't have the fortitude to
sit through just how boring this is
including the judge with his bane mask
he looks like it looks like moby in a
turtle shell bane
yeah maybe get a different mask because
it's hurting your ears yes
what you didn't hear the person who's
three feet next to you maybe take her
out of a fishbowl
i thought i thought he was playing the
dating game and they put him in a sound
season yeah it's quiz show he's 21.
he's cheating um all right we're going
to go take your chat here at
lotterycredit.com
mug club do consider joining up that's
what allows us to do this because this
will be demonetized
back then uh so
that's how we keep it alive right now
youtube thank you very much not really
we're gonna go take chat piss off